This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler
本期节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不纳税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时代的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。而就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特大帝征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了100%。是的，汤姆，那确实是一个巨大的变化，但另一个税收变革即将来临。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”计划。如果你对此有任何担忧，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一变革变得更加简单，
for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing. about this is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitise your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. This episode is brought to you by my favourite London review of books. William here from Empire briefly crossing the Gollhanger Network borders in our journey to unpick the complexities of the past. that history is not a straight line. It's a vast, intricate and complex tapestry. To truly understand a political revolution or the fall of a dynasty, you have to build up the picture
通过一个实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，帮助你遵守所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，劳埃德商业账户客户可以免费使用该工具。因此，当需要将所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。本期节目由我最喜欢的《伦敦书评》赞助播出。我是来自《帝国》播客的威廉，短暂跨越戈尔汉格网络（Goalhanger Network）的边界，踏上我们揭开过去复杂性的旅程。历史并非一条直线，它是一幅宏大、错综复杂且精妙的挂毯。要真正理解一场政治革命或一个王朝的覆灭，你必须一点一滴地构建起全貌，
piece by piece. You need diary entries and poetry that capture the scale of emotions, the secret correspondence of a diplomat and the sharp discerning insights of the era's great thinkers. And it's this art of the deep dive that the London Review of Books champions. They bring together the world's leading thinkers and interrogate a rich range of topics through long form essays. Try three months of the LRB completely free when you sign up today. Subscribe at LRB.me forward slash trial. That is LRB.m.m. forward slash trial to try three months of the London review of books for free. Just do it. It's the most wonderful journal in the country and you will never regret it. This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old
你需要日记条目和诗歌来捕捉情感的尺度，需要外交官的秘密通信，以及那个时代伟大思想家敏锐而深刻的见解。正是这种深度挖掘的艺术，成为了《伦敦书评》所推崇的宗旨。他们汇集了全球顶尖的思想家，通过长篇评论文章探讨丰富多样的议题。现在注册，即可免费试读《伦敦书评》三个月。请访问 LRB.me/trial 订阅。即 LRB.me/trial，免费试读三个月。一定要去试试，这是全国最精彩的杂志，你绝对不会后悔。今年春天，牛仔装迎来了更柔软、更轻盈的升级。隆重推出老海军（Old Navy）的垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤，
Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable and effortlessly cool. With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg. Gooden tag. And that was, of course, the national anthem of Germany.
这是一种随你而动的新版型。它拥有你想要夏天牛仔裤拥有的一切感觉：轻便、透气且毫不费力地时髦。这种版型营造出自然的动感，阔腿设计显得现代而不臃肿。此外，还有那种标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的惊喜时刻。老海军垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤。你好。那当然是德国的国歌。
And Dominic, this time in the World Cup, the Germans aren't kind of massive favorites, are they? But I mean, when it comes to European teams in the World Cup, the Germans are pretty irresistible. They've won the World Cup four times. They've been runners up four times. They have reached the last four 13 times, which is more even than the Brazilians. And as the co-founder of our own beloved production company put it, football is a simple game. 22 men chase a ball for 90 minutes, and at the end, the Germans always win. And the consequence of that is that football fans certainly have got used to hearing the German anthem a great deal.
多米尼克，这次世界杯德国队似乎不是夺冠大热门，对吧？但我的意思是，说到世界杯上的欧洲球队，德国队简直让人无法抗拒。他们四次赢得世界杯，四次获得亚军，13次打进四强，这甚至比巴西队还要多。正如我们心爱的制作公司联合创始人所说，足球是一项简单的运动：22个人追逐一个球90分钟，最后总是德国人获胜。其结果就是，足球迷们确实已经习惯了频繁听到德国国歌。
Yeah, that's right. There are, of course, other reasons why the German anthem is quite familiar, and that's not to do with football at all, but possibly to do with the history of Germany in the 20th century. And you think that as well as being incredibly familiar, it is also actually the most misunderstood because its roots are not kind of militaristic and its lyrics are not an assertion of German power over the rest of the world, as is often sometimes thought. Yeah, I do think that, Tom. I do think it's misunderstood. So I would say that if you would have to stop people in the streets in Britain and say to them,
是的，没错。当然，德国国歌之所以如此耳熟能详，还有其他原因，这与足球完全无关，可能与20世纪的德国历史有关。你认为它不仅非常熟悉，而且实际上是被误解最深的，因为它的根源并非军国主义，其歌词也不是像人们通常认为的那样，是对德国凌驾于世界之上的宣扬。是的，我确实这么认为，汤姆。我确实认为它被误解了。所以我想说，如果你在英国街头拦住路人问他们，
What is the German national anthem called? I think there's no doubt that most people would say, oh, everyone knows what it's called. It's called Deutschland Uber Alice. I mean, this is just the general assumption in Britain, I think, because we've been traumatized by so many war films. Yeah, and the Uber Alice means Germany number one. Yes, Germany over everybody else. Yeah. Actually, it's not called Deutscheland Uber Alice.
“德国国歌叫什么名字？”毫无疑问，大多数人会说：“哦，大家都知道它叫什么，叫《德国高于一切》（Deutschland über alles）。”我认为这在英国是一种普遍的假设，因为我们被太多的战争电影创伤了。是的，“高于一切”意味着德国第一。是的，德国凌驾于所有人之上。实际上，它并不叫《德国高于一切》。
It was written in 1841, and the title of the anthem is Das Lied der Deutsche, the Song of the Germans. And today, when you hear that anthem, so when, you know, in the 1980s, some unlovely German, West German team was storming to a European or world title with a massive mullet. Terrible mullets and mustaches, Rudy Vola or some such way. When they were to the horror of people around the world winning tournaments left, right and center, they never ever sang Deutsche Lund, Uber Alice. It's the kind of thing you would see in newspaper headline in Britain in the Daily Mirror or something. But they actually sing, Einikait and Recht and Freight, which Tom translates, as we both know, as unity and right and freedom. That is not as helpful, is it, to the headline writers of the Daily Mirror?
它写于1841年，国歌的标题是《德国人之歌》（Das Lied der Deutschen）。今天，当你听到那首国歌时——比如在20世纪80年代，一些留着大鬓角、发型糟糕的西德队球员正以那种糟糕的鬓角和胡子，比如鲁迪·沃勒尔之流，在欧洲或世界大赛中横扫千军时——当他们令全世界观众感到恐惧地赢得比赛时，他们从来没有唱过《德国高于一切》。这只是你在英国报纸头条，比如《每日镜报》上看到的那种说法。但他们实际上唱的是“Einigkeit und Recht und Freiheit”，汤姆，正如我们所知，翻译过来就是“团结、正义和自由”。这对《每日镜报》的标题撰稿人来说，可没那么好用，对吧？
Not at all, not at all. And that's because what Germans sing today is actually the third verse of the hymn, not the first. And this is for historical reasons that we will get into. So we will be talking about things like the Weimar Republic, the Third Reich, and so on, East Germany. So there's a lot to unpack in this episode. Yeah. I mean, it is controversial. Exactly.
一点也不，一点也不。这是因为德国人今天唱的实际上是这首赞美诗的第三段，而不是第一段。这有我们接下来要探讨的历史原因。所以我们将讨论魏玛共和国、第三帝国、东德等等。这一集有很多内容需要拆解。是的，我的意思是，这确实很有争议。没错。
So there were a couple of controversies actually just a few months ago, like last autumn. So first of all, there was a row when two AFD politicians, so politicians of the far right party, the AFD, they went to New York City and they were filmed singing the first verse in a bar with the president of the Young Republican Club of New York. So they were seeing a Deutsche and Ubarales there, and that was a bad look, I think, both for the Germans. I have to say, I think it was a bad look for the young Republican president as well. And at the same time, the vice president of D'Linka, the left-wing party in Germany, which is a descendant of the old Communist Party of East Germany. This is a guy called Bodo Ramelow, who actually used to be the minister-president of Turingia,
所以，就在几个月前，也就是去年秋天，确实发生了一些争议。首先，当两名德国极右翼政党德国选择党（AfD）的政客前往纽约市，并被拍到在一家酒吧里与纽约青年共和党俱乐部主席一起唱第一段歌词时，引发了一场风波。他们在那里唱了《德国高于一切》，我认为这对德国人来说形象很差。我必须说，我认为这对那位青年共和党主席来说形象也很差。与此同时，德国左翼党（Die Linke）的副主席，也就是东德旧共产党后裔政党的副主席，一个叫博多·拉梅洛（Bodo Ramelow）的人，他曾担任图林根州的州长，
of the estate in the east of Germany. And was actually from West Germany? Yes. So Bodo Ramalo said, I know many East Germans who do not sing the national anthem. And he said we should have a referendum on a new anthem. And what I would like is a song written in 1950 by Bertolt Brecht. And I quote,
那个位于德国东部的州。而且他实际上来自西德？是的。所以博多·拉梅洛说：“我认识许多不唱国歌的东德人。”他说我们应该就新国歌进行全民公投。我想要的是贝托尔特·布莱希特（Bertolt Brecht）在1950年写的一首歌。我引用一下，
a pan-German anthem that we could all sing together with joy. And we'll be coming back to this later on. I have a German friend who completely agrees, with that. Really? Yeah, she loves the Berto Brecht song. Well, come to the Bertolt Brecht song. But let's start with what is the anthem right now,
一首全德国的国歌，我们可以一起快乐地歌唱。我们稍后会回到这个话题。我有一个德国朋友完全同意这一点。真的吗？是的，她很喜欢贝托尔特·布莱希特的歌。好吧，我们稍后会谈到布莱希特的歌。但让我们先从现在的国歌开始，
the song of the Germans. So, Das Li de Deutsche. And I think it has actually perhaps the most fascinating history of any national anthem, including Tom, our own, which is a shocking thing to say. I mean, it didn't get there first, did it? I mean, that's the important thing. We got there first.
也就是《德国人之歌》。我认为它实际上拥有所有国歌中最迷人的历史，包括我们自己的，汤姆，这话说出来很惊人。我的意思是，它不是第一个出现的，对吧？我的意思是，这才是重点。我们是第一个。
Compared with their own, it is a latecomer. So we'll start with the tune. The tune is written 1797 by the Kemp. composer, Yosef Haydn. Haydn was an Austrian, that is to say, he was the subject of the Habsberg Empire. He's obviously one of the titans of 18th century classical music. So Hayden, for people who are not massively into their classical music, he's often seen as the person who invented the symphony, the string quartet, the sonata, Mozart and Beethoven are standing on Haydn's shoulders. He's a tremendous person to have as the writer of your national anthem.
与我们自己的相比，它是一个后来者。所以我们从曲调开始。曲调由肯普（Kemp）作曲家约瑟夫·海顿（Joseph Haydn）于1797年创作。海顿是奥地利人，也就是说，他是哈布斯堡帝国的臣民。他显然是18世纪古典音乐的泰斗之一。所以海顿，对于那些不太了解古典音乐的人来说，他通常被视为交响曲、弦乐四重奏、奏鸣曲的发明者，莫扎特和贝多芬都站在海顿的肩膀上。作为国歌的创作者，他是一个了不起的人选。
And he's a tremendous person because he's a massive fan of Nelson, isn't he? Oh, yes, of course. Yeah, I've forgotten that. He writes a mass, which comes to be called the Nelson Mass. And he hangs out with Nelson and Emma when they're on their comical procession across the continent. Exactly so. So, yeah, he's from an older generation than Mozart, say. So he spends most of his time basically as a glorified servant.
而且他是一个了不起的人，因为他是纳尔逊的超级粉丝，不是吗？哦，当然。是的，我忘了这一点。他写了一部弥撒曲，后来被称为《纳尔逊弥撒》。当纳尔逊和艾玛在欧洲大陆进行滑稽的巡游时，他经常和他们在一起。正是如此。所以，是的，他比莫扎特那一代人要年长。所以他大部分时间基本上是作为一个高级仆人，
He's the music director for the Estahazi family in Hungary. In 1790, Prince Estahazi had died. so Hyden was free to do what he liked and he went to London. And there he is a massive celebrity and he hears people, and don't forget this is in the context of the French Revolution and then the Napoleonic Wars. So he hears people singing God Save the King, which of course is very current at the time.
他是匈牙利埃斯特哈齐家族的音乐总监。1790年，埃斯特哈齐亲王去世了，所以海顿可以自由地做他想做的事，于是他去了伦敦。在那里，他是一位大名人，他听到人们唱歌——别忘了这是在法国大革命和随后的拿破仑战争背景下——他听到人们唱《天佑国王》，这在当时当然非常流行。
The first pop song. He comes back to Vienna and he's a great celebrity in Vienna as well. And he writes this in 1797 and there's a particular reason why he writes it. So 1797 is a very anxious man. for the Viennese. They're fighting against revolutionary France, but they've actually lost their territories in what becomes Belgium, and they're being absolutely hammered by the Revolutionary General Napoleon Bonaparte in Italy. And Haydn wants to do his bit to raise national morale. And he's just come back from London. There, everybody is singing, God Save the King, you know, down with the
第一首流行歌曲。他回到维也纳，在维也纳也是一位大名人。他在1797年写了这首歌，他写这首歌有一个特殊的原因。所以1797年对维也纳人来说是一个非常焦虑的年份。他们正在与革命的法国作战，但实际上已经失去了后来成为比利时的领土，并且在意大利被革命将军拿破仑·波拿巴打得落花流水。海顿想尽自己的一份力量来提振国民士气。他刚从伦敦回来。在那里，每个人都在唱《天佑国王》，你知道，打倒
French, down with Bonie, all of this. And to quote an official Austrian account written later, he envied the British nation for a song through which it could at festive occasions show in full measure its respect and love for its ruler. Hayden wished that Austria too could have a similar national anthem. And what's impressive about that is that we heard in our last episode that lots of countries copy the tune of God Save the King, like the assumption is that if you've got to have a national anthem, that's the tune that you have to have. But Hayden, as one of the great musicians, he's not going to be content with just ripping off
法国人，打倒波拿巴，诸如此类。引用后来写的一份官方奥地利记录的话说，他羡慕英国民族有一首歌，可以通过它在节日场合充分表达对统治者的尊重和爱戴。海顿希望奥地利也能有一首类似的国歌。令人印象深刻的是，我们在上一集听说许多国家抄袭了《天佑国王》的曲调，因为人们认为如果你必须有一首国歌，那这就是你必须拥有的曲调。但海顿作为伟大的音乐家之一，他不会满足于仅仅剽窃
the tune of God Save the King. He's going to write his own. And he deliberately says, he wants to write it to inflame the hearts of the Austrians to new heights of devotion to their princes and their fatherland. So he teams up with a poet called Lorenz Leopold Hushka to write an anthem. And they dedicate it to the Emperor Franz II, Francis II. And they first perform it on his birthday, 12th of February, 1797. And the first line is a bit of a rip-off of God Save the King.
《天佑国王》的曲调。他要写自己的。他特意说，他想写这首歌来激发奥地利人对他们的君主和祖国产生新的奉献热情。于是他与一位名叫洛伦茨·利奥波德·哈什卡（Lorenz Leopold Haschka）的诗人合作创作了一首国歌。他们把它献给了弗朗茨二世皇帝。他们于1797年2月12日在他生日那天首次演唱。第一行有点像《天佑国王》的翻版。
It is God save Franz the emperor. Gott erheltre Franz Dain Kaiser. So he hasn't ripped off the team, but he's ripped off the words. This guy, Lorenz-Leopold-Hashkar, I suppose, has ripped off the words. Anyway, as anyone who knows the German anthem will know, the tune is quite slow, quite stately. And there's a musicologist who's written about this called Michael Geisler, who is a German scholar working in the United States.
它是“天佑弗朗茨皇帝”。Gott erhalte Franz den Kaiser。所以他没有剽窃曲调，但他剽窃了歌词。这个叫洛伦茨·利奥波德·哈什卡的人，我想，剽窃了歌词。总之，任何熟悉德国国歌的人都知道，曲调相当缓慢、庄重。有一位研究过此事的音乐学家叫迈克尔·盖斯勒（Michael Geisler），他是一位在美国工作的德国学者。
And he argues that Hayden basically gets this from an Austrian. in folk song, that that's the inspiration for it. It's not a march. It is a sort of slow, stately, very hummable, this kind of music that would appeal to the masses, I suppose. But also, it's really interesting because if it's a folk song, this is the age of romanticism, the idea that folk songs arise from the kind of mass consciousness of the people, there is something of the romantic there, but also something of the tradition about the God Save the King, that it has risen from, you know, the ancient depths. It's perfectly calibrated, and for that reason, it's a massive hit.
他认为海顿基本上是从奥地利民歌中汲取的灵感，这就是它的灵感来源。它不是进行曲。它是一种缓慢、庄重、非常容易哼唱的音乐，我想这会吸引大众。但这也非常有趣，因为如果它是一首民歌，这正是浪漫主义时代，即民歌源于大众意识的观念，其中既有浪漫主义的成分，也有关于《天佑国王》的传统成分，即它源于古老的深处。它经过了完美的校准，正因如此，它大获成功。
Hayden is very proud of it. It is said that during his final illness in 1809, he played, this was the song that he played again and again on the piano, and his servant actually recorded this is the last thing Hayden ever played before he died. So, Austrian anthem, very popular, continues for decades, as an account from the 1840s, Who does not know the Austrian song, God Save the Emperor? Who is not, with heartfelt emotion often joined in singing it? It has penetrated the very blood of Austrian.
海顿对此非常自豪。据说在1809年他最后的病榻上，他一遍又一遍地在钢琴上弹奏这首歌，他的仆人记录下这是海顿去世前弹奏的最后一首曲子。所以，奥地利国歌非常受欢迎，持续了几十年，正如1840年代的一份记录所言：“谁不知道那首奥地利歌曲《天佑皇帝》？谁没有怀着真挚的情感经常加入合唱？它已经渗透到奥地利人的血液中，
is inhabitants, all of Germany honors it, and even in foreign lands, the lovely melody has found a welcome reception. And the welcome reception, people like Beethoven, Rossini, Burkna, Chikovsky, they all write adaptations of it or variations on it. But nobody at this stage doubts that it is Austrian and not German. It is a Habsburg anthem. And so now we get to the point where it turns into a German one. And the guy who does this is a poet with the excellent name of August Heinrich Hoffmann von Fathersleben. What is it? August Heinrich Hoffman von Flaasleben. Very good. Easy to say, Tom. That was the first take. Listeners, that was Dominic's sixth attempt. So he is from Lower Saxony, from Brunswick. He's the son of a merchant,
它的居民，整个德国都尊崇它，甚至在外国土地上，这美妙的旋律也受到了欢迎。”这种欢迎，像贝多芬、罗西尼、布鲁克纳、柴可夫斯基这样的人，都写过它的改编曲或变奏曲。但在现阶段，没有人怀疑它是奥地利的而不是德国的。这是一首哈布斯堡王朝的国歌。现在我们到了它变成德国国歌的时刻。做这件事的人是一位名字非常出色的诗人，奥古斯特·海因里希·霍夫曼·冯·法勒斯莱本（August Heinrich Hoffmann von Fallersleben）。是什么？奥古斯特·海因里希·霍夫曼·冯·法勒斯莱本。非常好。很容易说，汤姆。那是第一次录音。听众们，那是多米尼克的第六次尝试。所以他来自下萨克森州的布伦瑞克。他是商人的儿子，
and he became a professor of literature in Prussia, in Breslau, which was there. in Prussia, now it's in Poland. Now, Hoffman, we'll just call him Hoffman, he's idealistic, high-minded, he's very frustrated with what's happened to German politics after the end of the Napoleonic Wars. So he's a classic German intellectual in the period of the Napoleonic Wars? He's a total German intellectual. Wistful, yearning for all kinds of things that Germany doesn't have. Exactly.
后来成为普鲁士布雷斯劳的文学教授，那里当时在普鲁士，现在在波兰。现在，霍夫曼，我们就叫他霍夫曼，他理想主义、高尚，对拿破仑战争结束后德国政治发生的事情感到非常沮丧。所以他是拿破仑战争时期典型的德国知识分子？他是一个彻头彻尾的德国知识分子。忧郁，渴望着德国所没有的各种东西。正是如此。
Because what's happened is once the French invaded what becomes Germany in the Napoleonic Wars, You got a sort of dual process. On the one hand, people were inspired by the ideals of the French Revolution, but on the other hand, they reacted against French occupation. So this is a huge boost to the idea of German nationalism and the idea of uniting all German speakers in a single state. And a liberal state, so one that will stand up for freedom of the press and democratic citizenship and all these things.
因为发生的事情是，一旦法国入侵了后来成为德国的地区，在拿破仑战争中，你就经历了一个双重过程。一方面，人们受到法国大革命理想的启发，但另一方面，他们反抗法国的占领。所以这对德国民族主义的理念以及将所有德语使用者统一在一个单一国家中的想法是一个巨大的推动。而且是一个自由的国家，一个能够捍卫新闻自由、民主公民权和所有这些东西的国家。
So if you're a poet or a literature professor, or in this bloke's case, both, you're absolutely, you know, you're imbued with all this kind of thing. and you look at what's happened in the 1820s and 30s, so at the age of reaction, basically democratic ideals being put back in their box. So Waterloo, Napoleon has been defeated and the ideals of the French Revolution have been seemed to have been crushed. Yes, exactly so. And so this guy Hoffman is sitting there.
所以如果你是一位诗人或文学教授，或者像这家伙一样两者兼备，你绝对是沉浸在所有这些东西之中。你看看1820年代和30年代发生了什么，也就是反动时代，基本上民主理想被重新关进了盒子里。所以滑铁卢，拿破仑被击败了，法国大革命的理想似乎已经被粉碎了。是的，正是如此。所以这个叫霍夫曼的家伙坐在那里。
Now, he's already written one hymn. He's written that unusual thing, a song literally celebrating a customs union. It's a hymn celebrating the Zolverine, which is the... This German customs union that paves the way for German unity. So he's written this song. And in 1841, he's on holiday on the North Sea Island of Heligoland. And Heligoland at this point was owned by Britain. It's basically off the northern, North German coast.
现在，他已经写了一首赞美诗。他写了一首不同寻常的东西，一首字面上庆祝关税同盟的歌。这是一首庆祝德意志关税同盟（Zollverein）的赞美诗，它是……这个为德国统一铺平道路的德国关税同盟。所以他写了这首歌。1841年，他在北海的黑尔戈兰岛度假。当时的黑尔戈兰岛归英国所有。它基本上在北德海岸外。
Yeah, he's having a British holiday. He's having a British seaside holiday. And he's sitting there and he thinks, probably raining if it's a British seaside holiday, and he thinks to himself, well, I'll write another, these excellent songs. And he writes the song of the German. Germans, das lead der Deutsche. Now, today, as we've already discussed, the lyrics are seen as a little
是的，他在度英国式的假。他在度英国海滨假期。他坐在那里想，如果是英国海滨假期的话可能还在下雨，他心想，好吧，我会再写一首这些出色的歌曲。于是他写了《德国人之歌》，Das Lied der Deutschen。现在，正如我们已经讨论过的，歌词被认为有一点点
bit problematic in some quarters. I said that with the seriousness it deserved. So we should say a bit about them. So what you heard at the beginning of the programme is, as we've said, the third verse, Einichite and Reich and Freight. And when you look at the lyrics, they are your absolute standard national anthem bingo. So unity and rights and freedom for the German fatherland, let us strive for this together, brotherly with heart and hand, and so on and so forth. It's a kind of word salad, isn't it? It is a word salad. The second verse is, so this is the one before the third verse, obviously. Master of maths kicking in there. Good to see. Just explaining. So this is seen as inappropriate today, and because it is sexist. So Deutsche Fraun, Deutsche
在某些方面有点问题。我是带着应有的严肃态度说这句话的。所以我们应该谈谈它们。正如我们所说，你在节目开头听到的是第三段，Einigkeit und Recht und Freiheit（团结、正义与自由）。当你查看歌词时，它们绝对是国歌的标准配置。为了德国祖国，团结、正义与自由，让我们齐心协力，手挽手，兄弟般地奋斗，等等。这简直就是一种文字游戏，不是吗？确实是文字游戏。第二段是，显然这是第三段之前的那一段。数学大师上线了。很高兴看到。只是解释一下。所以这在今天被认为是不合适的，因为它是性别歧视的。因为Deutsche Frauen（德国女性），Deutsche
Troia, Deutsche Vine and Deutsche Sang. So this is German women, German loyalty, German wine, German song. And these are the things that inspire us to do noble deeds. Unfortunately, Tom, you cannot now say German women in that list because that implies that the people who are doing the deeds are men and that women are just like the wine and the song. They're being objectified, unfortunately. But maybe you could change it according to the sex or whoever is singing the song. Deutsche mention or something, would it be? Wouldn't that work? I mean, you should take this up with the...
Treue（德国忠诚），Deutsche Wein（德国美酒）和Deutsche Sang（德国歌声）。所以这是德国女性、德国忠诚、德国美酒、德国歌声。这些是激励我们做出高尚行为的事物。不幸的是，汤姆，你现在不能在那个列表中说“德国女性”，因为那暗示着做出这些行为的人是男性，而女性就像美酒和歌声一样。不幸的是，她们被物化了。但也许你可以根据性别或唱歌的人来改变它。比如“德国人民”之类的，行吗？那样不行吗？我的意思是，你应该和……
With the Germans. Yeah, with the Germans. Yeah. Send an email to the Germans and suggest your idea and see how you get on. So that's the second verse. Now, again, my master in maths, before the second verse is the first verse, which nobody sings. And this actually does start,
和德国人谈谈。是的，和德国人谈谈。给德国人发封邮件，提出你的想法，看看进展如何。这就是第二段。现在，再次重申，我的数学大师身份，在第二段之前是第一段，没人唱的那一段。它确实是以这个开头的，
Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutsche, Ube alas, Uber alas in der Welt. And this does not mean Germany over everybody else. A program for global conquest is not what it means. Right. So what does it mean? Well, Germany at this point doesn't exist. So the Germans couldn't invade and conquer anybody. Hoffman would have been amazed to hear people say this is militaristic and a call for expansionism. What it's actually a call for, the song is aimed at the people of the different states of Germany, this patchwork, this quilt, this mosaic of very fragmented statelets. And he is saying to the
Deutschland, Deutschland über alles, über alles in der Welt（德国，德国高于一切，高于世间万物）。这并不意味着德国凌驾于其他人之上。它指的不是一个全球征服计划。对。那它是什么意思呢？好吧，当时的德国并不存在。所以德国人不可能入侵和征服任何人。霍夫曼如果听到人们说这是军国主义和扩张主义的呼吁，一定会感到惊讶。这首歌实际上呼吁的是德国不同邦国的人民，这个拼凑的、像被子一样的、由非常分散的小邦国组成的马赛克。他是在对……说
those people and specifically to their rulers and their governments, put aside your differences, your jealousies, your petty regional loyalties and put the ideal of Germany first. So literally, it means Germany above everything else. Let's bury these petty grievances and unite around a collective ideal. So it's like the Oat Joy as the Anthem for the European Union. It's kind of implicitly saying, let's bury our differences and celebrate a greater whole. Exactly. That's what it is. And at the time, this is not a conservative idea, it's a liberal idea.
那些人，特别是他们的统治者和政府，放下你们的分歧、嫉妒、狭隘的地区忠诚，把德国的理想放在首位。所以字面意思就是德国高于一切。让我们埋葬这些琐碎的怨恨，围绕一个共同的理想团结起来。所以这就像欧盟的国歌《欢乐颂》一样。它有点含蓄地在说，让我们埋葬分歧，庆祝一个更伟大的整体。没错。就是这样。在当时，这不是一个保守的想法，而是一个自由主义的想法。
So the people who are singing this song and the people who love this kind of stuff are students, poets, long-haired people of all kinds, they love all this. There is one other controversial element in the first verse, though, and this is some geographical detail. So, von der Maas been and di Memel, von der Ech, bis and an bedel. Now, I don't know how your European geography is, Tom. Well, I know where the MERS is. Yes. Or the MASS, because it's coming up in our next episode. So there's the MERS runs down through from the Netherlands into France.
所以唱这首歌的人和喜欢这类东西的人是学生、诗人、各种长发的人，他们都喜欢这些。不过，第一段中还有一个有争议的元素，那就是一些地理细节。Von der Maas bis an die Memel, von der Etsch bis an den Belt（从马斯河到梅梅尔河，从埃奇河到贝尔特海峡）。现在，我不知道你的欧洲地理知识如何，汤姆。嗯，我知道马斯河在哪里。是的。或者说马斯河，因为它会在我们下一集中出现。所以马斯河是从荷兰流向法国的。
Then the next one is Di Mamel. This is the River Neiman, we would call this now. So that's kind of Poland, Lithuania kind of area. De Ech is the Adjjj, that's in Italy. And the last one, and in Belt. The belt, the little belt, is a Danish. straight off the coast of Jutland. Now, you might look at that and say, what's going on here?
接下来是梅梅尔河。我们现在称之为尼曼河。所以那是波兰、立陶宛一带。埃奇河是阿迪杰河，在意大利。最后一个，贝尔特海峡。贝尔特海峡，小贝尔特海峡，是丹麦的。在日德兰半岛海岸外的一个海峡。现在，你可能会看一眼然后说，这是怎么回事？
Yeah. Hoffman wants to construct this vast empire that includes other people's rivers. What's he thinking? Actually, what he's thinking is this. There was no German at this point. The map is very fluid. He's looking at the map and saying, well, there's kind of German speakers that way, that way, that way. it's just a sort of very vague ideal of roughly where Germany is.
是的。霍夫曼想要建立一个包含别人河流的庞大帝国。他在想什么？实际上，他在想的是：当时没有德国。地图非常不稳定。他看着地图说，嗯，那边、那边、那边都有讲德语的人。这只是一个非常模糊的理想，大致指德国在哪里。
It's absolutely not an irredentist kind of Gabrielle de Nouncio-style program. It's a bit menacing for the Danes. I mean, the Danes at this point could consult themselves that they actually exist, whereas the Germans don't. Sure, but I mean, you have poets coming up and kind of menacing you with lyrics. I think you are only saying that because you're aware of what happened subsequently. So at the autumn of 1841, the song is finished and it's first performed on the night of the 5th of October. We know exactly when. There's a liberal politician from Barden called Carl Vecke.
这绝对不是加布里埃尔·邓南遮那种收复失地主义的计划。这对丹麦人来说有点威胁。我的意思是，丹麦人此时可以安慰自己，他们确实存在，而德国人不存在。当然，但我的意思是，你有诗人走过来，用歌词威胁你。我想你这么说只是因为你知道后来发生了什么。所以在1841年秋天，这首歌完成了，并于10月5日晚上首次演出。我们确切地知道时间。有一位来自巴登的自由派政治家叫卡尔·韦克。
And he's visiting Hamburg where Hoffman and his mates are. Hoffman and his mates who are from a local choir, they go to this bloke's hotel, they sing songs outside by Torchlight. Of course they do. Annoying if Karl Vec wants to get some sleep, I suppose. Anyway, one of them is this song, the song of the Germans. Is it a massive hit? No, it doesn't really catch on. It's actually reprinted in some student songbooks. But unlike, say, the Star Spangled Banner, which we did last week, or God Save the King, which we also did last week, this is not an overnight hit by any means. People aren't, you know, running around the streets singing it or something. The next year, Hoffman loses his job as a professor in Breslau, because the Prussian authorities say this blokes a dangerous, subversive with his long hair and his hymns. Get rid. Do you think they've been nobbled by the Danes? Surely, definitely. So he goes off into exile in Switzerland. Six years later, revolution sweeps
他正在访问霍夫曼和他的伙伴们所在的汉堡。霍夫曼和他的伙伴们来自当地的一个合唱团，他们去这个人的酒店，在外面打着火把唱歌。当然他们会这么做。如果卡尔·韦克想睡觉，这肯定很烦人。总之，其中一首歌就是这首《德国人之歌》。它是大热门吗？不，它并没有真正流行起来。它实际上被转载在一些学生歌集中。但与我们上周提到的《星条旗》或我们也提到的《天佑国王》不同，这绝不是一夜成名的热门歌曲。人们并没有在街上跑来跑去唱它之类的。第二年，霍夫曼失去了他在布雷斯劳的教授职位，因为普鲁士当局说这家伙是个危险的颠覆分子，留着长发，唱着赞美诗。赶走他。你认为他们是被丹麦人收买了吗？肯定，绝对是。所以他流亡到了瑞士。六年后的革命席卷了
across Central Europe. We did an episode about this a couple of years ago. This is 1848. In 1848 with Professor Sir Christopher Clark. And for a brief moment, it looks as though all the German states are going to be united in a liberal, federal, you know, super state. But there's a lovely flag, a tricula of black, red and gold. But it doesn't really. But it doesn't doesn't happen. The Austrian and Prussian monarchies fight back. They suppress the revolution. Hoffman ends up being pardoned. He never gets to see his name in lights. He becomes very boringly. He becomes the librarian to the Duke of Rattibor. No, no one wants that. And he dies in obscurity in 1874. Can I just ask one question? So this kind of irredentist that you say isn't a redentist.
整个中欧。我们几年前做过一期关于这个的节目。这是1848年。在1848年，与克里斯托弗·克拉克爵士教授一起。在那一瞬间，看起来所有的德国邦国都要联合成一个自由的、联邦的、你知道的超级国家。但有一面可爱的旗帜，黑红金三色旗。但它并没有真正……但它并没有发生。奥地利和普鲁士君主制反击了。他们镇压了革命。霍夫曼最终被赦免了。他从未看到自己的名字在聚光灯下。他变得非常无聊。他成了拉蒂博公爵的图书管理员。不，没人想要那个。他在1874年默默无闻地去世了。我可以问一个问题吗？所以这种你说的收复失地主义，其实不是收复失地主义。
Yeah. Is Austria part of this? Is he kind of ambitious to see Austria become part of Germany? Well, if you think that the Adj, which is in Italy, that would imply that Austria would become part of this, yes. And I don't forget, until the advent of Bismarck, it's not clear that Germany will not include Habsburg, Catholic, Austria. In fact, there are lots of people going right into the 20th century who think that Austria should be part of Germany. And so if that's the case, is his kind of appropriation of the Austrian anthem a way of saying, well, what is good for Austria is good for all Germans? do you think? Yeah, I think possibly. I think people would recognize it by this point as an Austrian anthem, but don't forget it's that there already been different, we've already said, the different composers had written versions of it. So it's sort of gone viral, I suppose,
是的。奥地利是其中的一部分吗？他是否有雄心壮志看到奥地利成为德国的一部分？嗯，如果你认为在意大利的阿迪杰河意味着奥地利将成为其中的一部分，是的。而且别忘了，在俾斯麦出现之前，德国是否会包括哈布斯堡王朝统治下的天主教奥地利还不清楚。事实上，直到20世纪，还有很多人认为奥地利应该成为德国的一部分。所以如果是这样的话，他这种对奥地利国歌的挪用，是不是在说，对奥地利好的东西对所有德国人也都好？你觉得呢？是的，我想有可能。我想人们到那时会认出它是奥地利国歌，但别忘了，我们已经说过，不同的作曲家已经写过它的版本。所以它算是病毒式传播了，我想，
and is being adapted. But yeah, I think people would, in Germany, let's say in Hamburg, when they're first singing it by Torchlight, no one says, hold on, this is an Austrian anthem. I think they think it's completely reasonable that Germany would have, you know, that a song about the Germans would have an Austrian tune because the Austrians, of course, a part of the German family. That's what they think. Understood. Anyway, by the time he dies in 1874, Germany has become a reality. It is not the liberal federation that he and his friends envisaged.
并且正在被改编。但是的，我想在德国，比如在汉堡，当他们第一次打着火把唱它时，没人会说，等等，这是奥地利国歌。我想他们认为德国有一首关于德国人的歌用奥地利曲调是完全合理的，因为奥地利人当然是德国家庭的一部分。他们就是这么想的。明白了。总之，到他1874年去世时，德国已经成为现实。它不是他和他的朋友们所设想的自由联邦。
It's been created by Prussia, and particularly by Prussia's Minister-President Otto von Bismarck, with his policy of blood and iron. So actually what the Prussians have done, they fight three wars in six years against Denmark, the Danes again, Tom, Denmark, Austria, and France. and what they do is they well together all the German states except Austria in one empire. So there are 25 different states of this empire and the overall emperor is the king of Prussia. And the king of Prussia? Yeah.
它是由普鲁士创造的，特别是通过普鲁士首相奥托·冯·俾斯麦的“铁血”政策。所以实际上普鲁士人所做的是，他们在六年内打了三场战争，对抗丹麦——又是丹麦，汤姆，丹麦、奥地利和法国。他们所做的是将除奥地利以外的所有德国邦国合并成一个帝国。所以这个帝国有25个不同的邦国，总皇帝是普鲁士国王。普鲁士国王？是的。
Doesn't Prussia have our own beloved national anthem or at least it did for a time? It had the tune of God Save the Queen as its anthem. Yes, it does. So the Prussians do not adopt. the sing of the Germans. They see it as a part of the failed, long-haired liberal experiments of the 1840s. The Prussians have their own anthem. They don't share with the other parts of the empire.
普鲁士没有我们自己心爱的国歌吗？或者至少曾经有过？它曾以《天佑女王》的曲调作为国歌。是的，确实。所以普鲁士人没有采用《德国人之歌》。他们认为这是1840年代失败的、长发自由派实验的一部分。普鲁士人有自己的国歌。他们不与帝国的其他部分分享。
It's just the Prussian anthem. And you're absolutely right. The anthem is called Heil dear im Sieger Krantz. Hail to thee in the victor's crown. And it is a direct rip-off of God Save the King. So it goes, Heil dear im Sieger-Krantz. Herrsher des Vaterlands, Heil, Kaiser, dear, and so on and so forth.
那只是普鲁士国歌。你说得完全正确。这首歌叫《Heil dir im Siegerkranz》（向你致敬，胜利者的花环）。向你致敬，胜利者的花环。它是对《天佑国王》的直接抄袭。所以它是这样的：Heil dir im Siegerkranz, Herrscher des Vaterlands, Heil, Kaiser, dir（向你致敬，胜利者的花环，祖国的统治者，向你致敬，皇帝），等等等等。
They sing it better than I do. It is not popular outside Prussia. And the southern kingdoms of Bavaria and Wurttemberg, they're part of the empire, but they still have their own kings. They want nothing to do with this anthem. They just see it as Prussian rubbish. So actually the song that is much more popular across the Kaiser's Germany is another song which is called De Vacht Am Rhein, The Watch on the Rhine. So this is a similar vintage.
他们唱得比我好。它在普鲁士之外并不受欢迎。南部的巴伐利亚和符腾堡王国，它们是帝国的一部分，但它们仍然有自己的国王。它们不想和这首国歌有任何关系。它们只把它看作是普鲁士的垃圾。所以实际上在德意志帝国更受欢迎的歌是另一首，叫《Die Wacht am Rhein》（莱茵河守望）。所以这首歌的年代差不多。
It comes from 1840, but it's not a sort of long-haired liberal song at all. It's a much more militaristic song. So in 1840, there was a brief panic that the French were going back to their old tricks, and they were going to invade and seize the Rhineland. And a poet, another poet, though not a sort of, not a pacifist poet, a manly poet, a manly poet with the excellent name of Max Schneckenberger, wrote a poem and he called on all patriotic Germans to make sure no enemy ever sets his foot on the shore of the Rhine. So the chorus, in English, Dear Fatherland, put your mind at rest, firm and true stands the watch, the watch on the Rhine. And because it's
它来自1840年，但它根本不是那种长发自由派的歌。它是一首更具军国主义色彩的歌。所以在1840年，曾有过短暂的恐慌，担心法国人会重操旧业，入侵并夺取莱茵兰。一位诗人，另一位诗人，虽然不是那种和平主义诗人，而是一位有男子气概的诗人，一位名字极好的有男子气概的诗人，叫马克斯·施内肯伯格，写了一首诗，他呼吁所有爱国的德国人确保没有任何敌人能踏上莱茵河岸。所以副歌，用英语说，亲爱的祖国，请放心，坚定而真实地守望着，莱茵河上的守望。而且因为它
militaristic and because it is anti-French, soldiers sing it in the Franco-Prussian War of 187071. It becomes a massive hit in Germany. Bismarck loves it and he gives Schneckenberger's widow and annual pension. So if Germany has an anthem at this point, it's probably closer to being the Watch on the Rhine. Meanwhile, the song of the Germans, people have kind of forgotten about it by this point. To quote Michael Geisler,
具有军国主义色彩，而且它是反法的，士兵们在1870-71年的普法战争中唱它。它在德国成了巨大的热门。俾斯麦很喜欢它，他给了施内肯伯格的遗孀一笔年金。所以如果德国当时有一首国歌，它可能更接近《莱茵河守望》。与此同时，《德国人之歌》，人们到那时已经有点忘记它了。引用迈克尔·盖斯勒的话，
it's mouldering away in the basement of a Hamburg publishing house, which is nothing, not a fate anyone would welcome. But then it's again the British, the British re-entered the story. So it's an interaction with the British that revives it. In July 1890, Britain and Germany sign a treaty to swap some territory. So the British get Zanzibar and a bit of Kenya. The Germans get another bit of East Africa, and they get Heligoland.
它在汉堡一家出版社的地下室里发霉，这不是任何人会欢迎的命运。但后来又是英国人，英国人重新进入了故事。所以是与英国人的互动使它复活了。1890年7月，英国和德国签署了一项交换领土的条约。所以英国人得到了桑给巴尔和肯尼亚的一部分。德国人得到了东非的另一部分，他们得到了黑尔戈兰岛。
I'm really sad about that. You'd like Heligoland still be British. I'd have loved to have kept it, yeah. What would you do with it? I would make a massive naval base. Yeah, that would have been fun in the First World War. I'd menace the Baltic and the German coast. You've blockade Lubeck or something.
我对此感到非常难过。你希望黑尔戈兰岛仍然是英国的。我本来很想保留它，是的。你会用它做什么？我会建立一个巨大的海军基地。是的，那在第一次世界大战中会很有趣。我会威胁波罗的海和德国海岸。你会封锁吕贝克之类的。
You see, I feel Britain got the worst of that deal. You don't rate Zanzibar, clearly, which is sad. I mean, it's a bit far away, isn't it? I guess so. The Heligoland's colder. But I can imagine you going there for some sort of seaside break. A bracing walk. Bracing walking holiday.
你看，我觉得英国在那笔交易中吃了大亏。你显然不看重桑给巴尔，这很可悲。我的意思是，它有点远，不是吗？我想也是。但黑尔戈兰岛更冷。但我可以想象你去那里度个海滨假。一次令人振奋的散步。令人振奋的徒步假期。
Exactly. Anyway, Heligoland has been lost to Britain, which is sad for you. There's an official ceremony to mark its incorporation to the German Empire. and the organisers at this ceremony say, well, ideally, could there be a song written in Heligoland that celebrates German unity? Menacing the Danes, perhaps? And they scout around in the basement of this Hamburg publishing house,
没错。总之，黑尔戈兰岛已经失去了，这对你来说很可悲。有一个正式的仪式来标志它并入德意志帝国。仪式的主办方说，好吧，理想情况下，能不能写一首在黑尔戈兰岛唱的歌来庆祝德国统一？也许威胁一下丹麦人？他们在汉堡那家出版社的地下室里搜寻，
and guess what? They blow the dust off it. Unbelievable. Such a song exists. So they sing it at the ceremony, and now it starts to catch on. And it's played in the 1890s, and student groups start to sing it and whatnot.
你猜怎么着？他们吹掉了上面的灰尘。难以置信。确实有这样一首歌。所以他们在仪式上唱了它，现在它开始流行起来了。它在1890年代被演奏，学生团体开始唱它之类的。
Not everybody liked it. So Nietzsche, I know you're very interested in Nietzsche. Nietzsche hated the German anthem. Did he kind of want a Wagner opera or something? Go on for seven hours. I think what he didn't like about it, he just thought it was bass and Philistine. Well, it is. I mean, that's the point, isn't it?
并不是每个人都喜欢它。尼采，我知道你对尼采很感兴趣。尼采讨厌德国国歌。他是不是想要一部瓦格纳歌剧之类的？唱上七个小时。我想他不喜欢它的地方在于，他只是觉得它庸俗且市侩。嗯，确实。我的意思是，重点就在这里，不是吗？
Yeah, I suppose. He didn't approve of the nationalism of the late 19th century. He kind of gave up his German citizenship. He did. Exactly, exactly. So that's the first moment that enshrines it. The second moment we actually already mentioned on the show. So, Germany entered the First World War on the 1st of August 1914, and on the trains, the Prussian soldiers, when they go to war, they're singing, Haileadir im Siegocrat.
是的，我想是这样。他不赞成19世纪末的民族主义。他放弃了他的德国国籍。他确实放弃了。没错，没错。所以这是第一个让它神圣化的时刻。第二个时刻我们实际上已经在节目中提到了。所以，德国在1914年8月1日参加了第一次世界大战，在火车上，普鲁士士兵去打仗时，他们唱的是《Heil dir im Siegerkranz》。
Now, unfortunately, this is that the same tune as God Save the King. So it's not appropriate. So it's like the England fans booing. Liechtenstein, exactly. So the Prussians actually did get a composer called Hugo Cowen to write a new tune, but it didn't really catch on. Meanwhile, the lot of people are singing The Watch on the Rhine. So to quote one old soldier's memoir of the First World War, he's on his way to the front.
现在，不幸的是，这和《天佑国王》是同一个曲调。所以这不合适。所以这就像英格兰球迷嘘声一样。列支敦士登，没错。所以普鲁士人确实找了一位叫雨果·考恩的作曲家写了一首新曲子，但它并没有真正流行起来。与此同时，很多人在唱《莱茵河守望》。所以引用一位老兵关于第一次世界大战的回忆录，他在去前线的路上。
And he says, for the first time I saw the Rhine as we rode westward along its quiet waters to defend this, the German stream of streams from the greed of the old enemy. It means the French. The old watch on the Rhine roared out of the endless transport train into the morning sky. I felt as if my heart would burst. And Dominic, who is this old German soldier? Are you about to pull a trick that you have been known to play before? Yeah, it's a trick that's...
他说，当我沿着莱茵河静谧的水域向西行驶，去保卫这德国河流中的河流，免受老敌人的贪婪侵害时，我第一次看到了莱茵河。指的是法国人。古老的《莱茵河守望》从无尽的运输列车中咆哮而出，冲向晨空。我感觉我的心都要炸开了。多米尼克，这位德国老兵是谁？你是不是要玩你以前玩过的那种把戏？是的，这是一种……
So this is testing listeners whether they listen to our original First World War series. Because this kindly old soldier is actually the worst man in history. It's Adolf Hitler. So Hitler remembers singing the watch on the Rhine on the train. And then they get to the front. And there's a scene again that we mentioned in our First World War series. Hitler says, as he goes into action, from the distance the strains of a song reached our ears coming closer and closer, blah, blah, blah.
所以这其实是在测试听众是否听过我们最初的第一次世界大战系列节目。因为这位和蔼的老兵实际上是历史上最坏的人。他就是阿道夫·希特勒。希特勒记得在火车上唱过《守卫莱茵河》。然后他们到达了前线。又出现了我们在第一次世界大战系列中提到的那个场景。希特勒说，当他投入战斗时，远处传来了歌声，越来越近，等等等等。
The song reached us and we passed it along. Deutschland, Deutschland, Uber Alice, Uber Alice in der Welt. And what he's doing, as we talked about before, is Hitler is repeating one of the great German legends of the First World War, the story of the Kindermort, the idea that's place at Langermark in November 1914, student volunteers go into action in heavy fog, they're moaned down by the British and they are singing the song of the Germans. And this was reprinted in loads of German newspapers at the time. It's probably an element of truth in it because there are accounts by British and French soldiers saying, remember people doing this. And of course, we've already said it's not a militaristic song. And I think this is what makes that story so powerful. Because they're singing an idealistic song about their love of the idea of Germany. It's Germany above all else.
歌声传到了我们这里，我们也跟着唱了起来。德国，德国，高于一切，高于世间万物。正如我们之前所讨论的，希特勒所做的是在重复第一次世界大战中德国最伟大的传说之一，即“兰格马克之死”的故事，这个故事发生在1914年11月的兰格马克，学生志愿者在浓雾中投入战斗，被英国人扫射，而他们当时正在唱着德国人之歌。这在当时被大量德国报纸转载。这其中可能有一部分事实，因为有英国和法国士兵的记录说，记得有人这样做过。当然，我们已经说过，这不是一首军国主义歌曲。我认为这正是这个故事如此强大的原因。因为他们唱的是一首关于他们对德国理念之爱的理想主义歌曲。这就是德国高于一切。
It's students, isn't it, as well? So again, a kind of link back to that dreamy philosophical age. It's a much more powerful story because it's this utopian. idealistic song, then if it had been the wash on the Rhine, or, you know, a song about the Emperor of Prussia or whatever. Yeah, it's doomed youth. Domed youth, exactly. Anyway, as everybody knows, Germany loses the First World War, the Kaiser's overthrown, the empire's abolished.
这也是学生，对吧？所以这又是一种与那个梦幻般的哲学时代的联系。这是一个更有力的故事，因为它是一首乌托邦式的、理想主义的歌曲，而不是《守卫莱茵河》，或者，你知道，一首关于普鲁士皇帝之类的歌。是的，这是注定毁灭的青春。注定毁灭的青春，没错。总之，正如大家所知，德国输掉了第一次世界大战，德皇被推翻，帝国被废除。
You've got the new Weimar Republic takes power. It's Germany is humiliated. It's been, you know, dismembered, everybody's very embittered. Bled of reparations and all kinds of things. Reparations, the Treaty of Versailles. exactly. The new leaders are trying to find symbols around which Germany can unite. One obvious one is the flag. So there are flag wars, flag controversies all the way through the 20s. People can't agree on what flag to fly. If you're on the right, you want the old flag, which is black, white and red.
新的魏玛共和国上台了。德国受到了羞辱。你知道，它被肢解了，每个人都非常痛苦。被赔款和各种各样的事情榨干了。赔款，凡尔赛条约。没错。新的领导人正试图找到德国可以团结起来的象征。一个显而易见的象征就是国旗。所以整个20年代都有旗帜战争，旗帜争议。人们无法就悬挂什么旗帜达成一致。如果你是右翼，你想要旧国旗，也就是黑、白、红三色旗。
If you're on the center, on the left, you go with the government-approved flag, which is the black, red, gold flag of 1848. That's the flag that the German. have today. But the first president of the Weimar Republic, who is a social democrat, he's Friedrich Ebert, he says, look, we've got to give the conservative something. If they're not going to get the flag, we've got to give them something. I want to have the army on board. You know, I don't want them against me. And so on the third anniversary of the Weimar constitution in August 1922, he decided to give them the song that had played such a key part in that story about the trenches, the Kindermode story, the story about the students being shot.
如果你是中间派或左翼，你会选择政府批准的旗帜，也就是1848年的黑、红、金三色旗。那是德国人今天使用的旗帜。但魏玛共和国的第一任总统，一位社会民主党人，弗里德里希·艾伯特，他说，看，我们必须给保守派一些东西。如果他们得不到国旗，我们必须给他们别的东西。我想让军队站在我这边。你知道，我不想让他们反对我。所以，在1922年8月魏玛宪法颁布三周年之际，他决定把那首在战壕故事、兰格马克之死故事、学生被枪杀的故事中起到关键作用的歌曲送给他们。
So this, of course, is the Song of the Germans. And in his speech announcing it, actually, he doesn't talk about the first verse, Deutsche Döber Alas, he talks about the third verse, which is the one Germans sing today. And he says in his speech, unity and right and freedom,
所以这当然就是《德国人之歌》。在他宣布这一决定的演讲中，他实际上并没有谈论第一段“德国，高于一切”，他谈论的是第三段，也就是德国人今天唱的那一段。他在演讲中说，统一、正义和自由，
in times of internal fragmentation and oppression, this triad from the poet's song voiced to the longing of all Germans. Let it accompany us now on our arduous path to a better future. So basically, he thinks everyone can unite around this song. There's something here for the liberals. There's something here for the conservatives because of its First World War Associations.
在内部四分五裂和压迫的时代，这首诗人歌曲中的三位一体表达了所有德国人的渴望。让它现在陪伴我们走上通往更美好未来的艰苦道路。所以基本上，他认为每个人都可以围绕这首歌团结起来。这对自由派来说有意义，对保守派来说也有意义，因为它与第一次世界大战有关。
And it will smooth the path towards a better Germany. And how does that work out? That doesn't work out well. So he dies of appendicitis in 1925. He's succeeded by Paul von Hindenburg, Prussian Warus. He hates the Social Democrats. He doesn't really believe in the Weimar Republic. and in January 1933, as so many of our listeners will know,
它将为通往一个更好的德国铺平道路。结果如何呢？结果并不好。所以他在1925年死于阑尾炎。继任者是普鲁士战争英雄保罗·冯·兴登堡。他讨厌社会民主党。他并不真正相信魏玛共和国。而在1933年1月，正如我们许多听众所知，
Hindenburg appoints us his new chancellor, the man who wrote that memoir about singing Deutschland Uber Alice going into battle, and that man is, of course, the worst man in history, Adolf Hitler. So, after the break, we will find out what happens to Germany's national anthem under the Nazis and whether the Nazis have any other anthems that they might like to see adopted. we will then investigate the strange story of East Germany's communist anthem
兴登堡任命了我们的新总理，那个写了关于在战斗中唱《德国高于一切》回忆录的人，那个人当然就是历史上最坏的人，阿道夫·希特勒。所以，休息之后，我们将了解德国国歌在纳粹统治下发生了什么，以及纳粹是否还有其他他们可能希望采用的国歌。然后我们将调查东德共产主义国歌的奇怪故事，
and also the anthem we've already mentioned that was written by Bertolt Brecht, the great German playwright. And Dominic, we will explore just why the German anthem remains controversial to this day. So lots to look forward to. See you soon. This episode is brought to you by The Times and the Sunday Times. Tom, as another summer of top international football returns, it's truly incredible, isn't it, to think about how much the world has changed between the various tournaments. Looking back to when England hosted back in 1966, everyone in the crowd supporting England were waving Union jacks.
以及我们已经提到的由伟大的德国剧作家贝尔托·布莱希特创作的国歌。多米尼克，我们将探讨为什么德国国歌至今仍有争议。所以有很多值得期待的内容。很快再见。本集由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》赞助播出。汤姆，随着又一个顶级国际足球之夏的回归，想到世界在各届锦标赛之间发生了多大的变化，真是令人难以置信，不是吗？回想1966年英格兰主办比赛时，人群中支持英格兰的人都在挥舞着英国国旗。
So what fascinating trends does that illustrate? And I suppose the last time the United States hosted the tournament was in 1994 and the mood in America in the early 1990s, you know, the Cold War was over. Clinton was in the White House. I was there for that. I was in Boston. Really? I mean, that's an aspect of the story that's very rarely reported on your presence. I know. So you know what this reminds me of, Tom? It reminds me that the future is always uncertain. You never know what's coming. But the facts need not be uncertain. And when the world feels like it's moving too fast, the times and the Sunday times empower you to make smarter, more confident decisions. Click or tap the banner now to learn more.
那么这说明了什么迷人的趋势呢？我想美国上一次主办锦标赛是在1994年，90年代初美国的氛围，你知道，冷战结束了。克林顿在白宫。我当时就在那里。我在波士顿。真的吗？我的意思是，这是关于你的经历中很少被报道的一个方面。我知道。所以你知道这让我想起了什么吗，汤姆？它让我想起未来总是充满不确定性。你永远不知道会发生什么。但事实不必是不确定的。当世界感觉变化太快时，《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》让你能够做出更明智、更自信的决定。点击或轻按横幅了解更多信息。
or visit the times.com. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision,
或访问thetimes.com。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克Optiq是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统找到你的节奏。这座城市需要敏捷，而Optiq以精准交付，
to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca.ca. Luxury sales claim based on SMP Global Mobility, Canadian new vehicle total registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. AI is moving fast across the enterprise. But without visibility, it's just chaos. Different tools, different models, different teams using AI in completely different ways.
让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们开凯迪拉克吧。在CadillacCanada.ca了解更多信息。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动，2025日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克对豪华车的定义。人工智能在企业中发展迅速。但如果没有可见性，那只是混乱。不同的工具、不同的模型、不同的团队以完全不同的方式使用人工智能。
Service Now turns that chaos into control. With the AI control tower, you see all your AI across the business in one place. What it's doing, what it's done, and what it's about to do. So you stay in control. To put AI to work for people, visit service now.com. Hello, everyone, and welcome back to the rest of history. It is January 1933, and Adolf Hitler has just been appointed the Chancellor of Germany. And Dominic, as everyone will know, Hitler despises the Weimar Republic.
ServiceNow将这种混乱转化为控制。通过人工智能控制塔，你可以在一个地方看到整个业务中的所有人工智能。它在做什么，它做了什么，以及它即将做什么。所以你保持控制。要让人工智能为人类服务，请访问servicenow.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1933年1月，阿道夫·希特勒刚刚被任命为德国总理。多米尼克，正如大家所知，希特勒鄙视魏玛共和国。
He wants to tear it to pieces. But what is he to do about this anthem, the song of the Germans, which was adopted only 11 years earlier and which he had heard being sung by doomed students on the Western Front. So on the downside, it's Weimar, on the positive side, he associates it with German heroism, fighting the enemy. Yes, meaning is ambiguous, isn't it? And Hitler doesn't scrap it, even though it's associated with the Weimar Republic. Actually, you can see why those opening words, Deutschland, Deutschland, Uber Alice, Germany above everything.
他想把它撕成碎片。但他该如何处理这首国歌——《德国人之歌》呢？这首歌仅仅在11年前才被采用，而且他曾听过注定毁灭的学生在西线唱过它。所以从消极的一面来看，它是魏玛的产物，从积极的一面来看，他把它与德国英雄主义、与敌人作战联系在一起。是的，含义很模糊，不是吗？希特勒并没有废除它，尽管它与魏玛共和国有关。实际上，你可以看出为什么那些开场白“德国，德国，高于一切”……
Yeah, you can reinterpret it, right? Yeah, even though Hoffman meant them differently, if you're a Nazi, they fit your creed quite nicely. So the Nazis do keep it as a national anthem, but there's a tweak. So I mentioned before the break, Friedrich Ebert, when he adopted the anthem in 1922, said, let's sing the third verse, unity and right and freedom. The Nazis say, forget the third verse. Let's go for the first. Let's sing that verse first, Germany above all.
是的，你可以重新诠释它，对吧？是的，即使霍夫曼的意思不同，如果你是纳粹，它们也非常符合你的信条。所以纳粹确实保留了它作为国歌，但有一个调整。所以我刚才在休息前提到，弗里德里希·艾伯特在1922年采用这首歌时说，让我们唱第三段，统一、正义和自由。纳粹说，忘掉第三段吧。让我们选第一段。让我们先唱那一段，德国高于一切。
And of course it's very effective. If you're a German nationalist, if you see, you know, the opening of the Berlin Olympics, Hitler comes in to a stadium full of thousands of people singing, Deutschland, Deutschland, Uber Alice. If you're a nationalist, this is classic, you know, Nazi theatre. Your heart sings with the sound of it. But there is a complication because this is not the only song that the Nazis want you to sing. by this point by the Berlin Olympics,
当然，这非常有效。如果你是一个德国民族主义者，如果你看到，你知道，柏林奥运会的开幕式，希特勒走进一个坐满成千上万人的体育场，人们唱着“德国，德国，高于一切”。如果你是一个民族主义者，这就是经典的，你知道，纳粹戏剧。你的心会随着它的声音而歌唱。但有一个复杂的情况，因为这不是纳粹希望你唱的唯一一首歌。到柏林奥运会时，
the song of the Germans is competing with an anthem that is much dearer to the Nazis' hearts and this is a song called the Horst Vessel Lied, which was written in 1929 by the paramilitary stormtrooper commander horsed vessel. And Tom, you know a lot about this guy, don't you?
《德国人之歌》正在与一首纳粹心中更珍贵的国歌竞争，这就是一首名为《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》的歌曲，它是由准军事冲锋队指挥官霍斯特·威塞尔于1929年创作的。汤姆，你对这家伙了解很多，不是吗？
I don't mean that's an indictment of you. I mean, it's a tribute to your scholarship. He features in Dominion. I have to say, that's why I know about it. Yeah. So we talked about him in the series we did on The Rise of the Nazis. So I can't remember what episode it is, but it's there somewhere. Yeah.
我不是说这是对你的指控。我的意思是，这是对你学术研究的赞美。他在《统治》一书中出现过。我必须说，这就是我了解它的原因。是的。所以我们在关于《纳粹的崛起》的系列节目中谈论过他。我不记得是哪一集了，但它就在那里。是的。
So just to say, he was a Berlin law student. He was enthusiastic Nazi. He was a brown shirt. He was an anti-communist who would lead members of his squad through the streets of Berlin, beating up reds and all of that. And he is shot dead by communist paramilitaries in 1930. He's only 22. There's been a big argument about his girlfriend who is also a prostitute and there's to do with the rent and all kinds of things like that.
所以只是说，他是一名柏林法律系学生。他是一个狂热的纳粹分子。他是一名褐衫军。他是一个反共分子，会带领他的小队成员穿过柏林的街道，殴打红军等等。他在1930年被共产主义准军事人员枪杀。他才22岁。关于他的女朋友，她也是一名妓女，还有关于房租和各种各样的事情，一直有很大的争论。
So it's all very squalid and not remotely heroic. But Goebbels isn't going to be worried by something like that. He completely rewrites the story, turns vessel into this kind of martyr and vehicle for Nazi PR. And then when the Nazis come to power in 1933, he turns him into a national figure. the kind of the embodiment of the good Nazi, the almost divine figure who other Germans should aspire to. Yes, exactly right. And part of this is the song. Vessel had written songs himself marching songs.
所以这一切都非常肮脏，一点也不英勇。但戈培尔不会被这种事情困扰。他完全重写了这个故事，把威塞尔变成了这种烈士和纳粹公关的工具。然后当纳粹在1933年上台时，他把他变成了一个国家级人物。那种好纳粹的化身，那种其他德国人应该向往的近乎神圣的人物。是的，完全正确。这首歌就是其中的一部分。威塞尔自己也写过歌，行军歌曲。
Yeah, for when they're kind of marching through Berlin, kind of roughing up the reds. And it actually had one published in a Nazi paper. And this is it. Di Fanahoch, the Ryan Fest, a schlosset, mit ruig festum schreit, raised the flag, the ranks tightly closed,
是的，当他们在柏林行军时，那种粗暴对待红军的时候。它实际上在一家纳粹报纸上发表过。就是这首，《旗帜高扬，行列紧闭，坚定不移地前进》，
the SA marches with calm and steady step. And he borrowed the tune from a naval song, the Kurnigsburg lead, which has been popular in the First World War. So it's a classic example. We've had this already multiple times in this National Anthem series
冲锋队以冷静而稳定的步伐行进。他从一首海军歌曲《柯尼斯堡之歌》中借用了曲调，这首歌在第一次世界大战中很受欢迎。所以这是一个经典的例子。我们在这一系列国歌节目中已经多次提到过，
of people taking a familiar tune because they know that will get them a better audience. The Nazis love this song. They sing it at rallies. Whenever you go to a beer hall, people are singing it. It's their answer to the Internationale of the Communists. And Hitler made it official in 1933. It was declared as a national symbol.
人们采用熟悉的曲调，因为他们知道这会为他们赢得更好的听众。纳粹喜欢这首歌。他们在集会上唱它。无论你走进哪家啤酒馆，人们都在唱它。这是他们对共产主义者《国际歌》的回应。希特勒在1933年将其正式化。它被宣布为国家象征。
And then in 1934, there was a government edict that basically whenever it was played, you had to give the Nazi salute. Well, you know, it literally becomes an anthem because the Protestant churches pick it up. And they sing it on kind of Reformation Day. It's incredible, isn't it? Yeah, it's kind of sanctified. Yeah, I saw that detail. They sang it in churches.
然后在1934年，政府发布了一项法令，基本上规定无论何时播放这首歌，你都必须行纳粹礼。嗯，你知道，它确实成为了一首国歌，因为新教教会采用了它。他们在宗教改革日之类的日子里唱它。真是不可思议，不是吗？是的，它被神圣化了。是的，我看到了那个细节。他们在教堂里唱它。
And I just thought, well, the Protestant churches, some of them are so close to Nazism, aren't they? The kind of ring-raith churches, yeah. Yeah. Anyway, it becomes the musical emblem of the Third Reich. So if you were to go onto YouTube and watch some random documentary, BBC documentary, about the Nazis, there's undoubtedly a point where it's playing in the background and there's people marching in, torchlight or something. Yeah, kind of fair-haired members of the Hitler youth, beaming. Exactly. So when Germany loses the war in 1945, both the tune of the Horst Vessel lead and the lyrics
我当时就想，嗯，新教教会，他们中的一些人与纳粹主义走得太近了，不是吗？那种“帝国教会”，是的。是的。总之，它成为了第三帝国的音乐标志。所以如果你去YouTube上看一些关于纳粹的随机纪录片，BBC纪录片，毫无疑问，在某个时刻它会在背景中播放，人们在火炬游行中行进之类的。是的，那种金发的希特勒青年团成员，满面笑容。没错。所以当德国在1945年输掉战争时，霍斯特·威塞尔之歌的曲调和歌词
were banned. And they're banned to the extent that in 2011, there was a police investigation into Amazon and Apple, and both of them had to take it down from their websites. And there was a court ruling in the German Supreme Court or whatever in 2009 ruled that you cannot even put the first words, Defana Hoch, on a t-shirt. You can't wear a t-shirt with the first three words of the horsed vessel lead. It is seen as so toxic.
都被禁止了。它们被禁止的程度是，在2011年，警方对亚马逊和苹果进行了调查，他们都不得不将其从网站上撤下。2009年德国最高法院的一项裁决规定，你甚至不能把“旗帜高扬”这几个字印在T恤上。你不能穿印有《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》前三个字的T恤。它被视为太有毒了。
So as the German national anthem, that's a bastard flush. Yes. Yes, chances of becoming the post-war anthem are nil, or precisely nil. So, yeah, we're in, we've got it's 1945, Germany devastated, defeated. This is what the Germans called
所以作为德国国歌，那是不可能的。是的。是的，成为战后国歌的可能性为零，或者确切地说是零。所以，是的，我们现在是1945年，德国满目疮痍，战败。这就是德国人所说的
Stunter nul, zero hour. And as lots of listeners will know, Germany was divided into four occupation zones. The Soviet zone in 1949 became East Germany. And we'll come to East Germany in a second, but for now we'll stick with the three Western zones, which in May 1949 had become the Federal Republic of Germany, West Germany. So West Germany, the people who run West Germany have a very complicated and conflicted attitude to German history. On the one hand, West Germany, it claims a fundamental. fundamental continuity with earlier German states.
“零点时刻”。正如许多听众所知，德国被划分为四个占领区。苏联占领区在1949年变成了东德。我们稍后会谈到东德，但现在我们先谈谈三个西部占领区，它们在1949年5月变成了德意志联邦共和国，即西德。所以西德，管理西德的人对德国历史有着非常复杂和矛盾的态度。一方面，西德声称与早期的德国国家有着根本的
So the West German leadership say we are tracing our lineage back to the 19th century, to all those long-haired poets, to the 1848 revolutions, to a buried tradition of German idealism. Yeah. On the other hand, West Germanists politicians say, well, 1945 is a great break and a chance for a completely new beginning. The Weimar Republic was a failure. The third right was a criminal aberration. all previous political constitutional arrangements are null and void. We have a totally clean slate and we are starting again from scratch.
连续性。所以西德领导层说，我们正在追溯我们的血统到19世纪，到所有那些长发诗人，到1848年的革命，到一种被埋没的德国理想主义传统。是的。另一方面，西德政治家说，嗯，1945年是一个巨大的转折点，是一个全新开始的机会。魏玛共和国是一个失败。第三帝国是一个犯罪的偏差。所有以前的政治宪法安排都无效。我们有一个完全干净的石板，我们正在从头开始。
Now that's not quite how it works because obviously the flag, they dust down the old 1848 flag. And then there's the anthem. And right from the start, people on the sort of centre right of German politics. So Christian Democrats. So like Adonauer, the first chancellor. Yeah, like Conrad Adonauer. They say, let's have the song of the Germans.
现在情况并非完全如此，因为显然国旗，他们掸去了旧的1848年国旗上的灰尘。然后是国歌。从一开始，德国政坛中右翼的人士。比如基督教民主党人。比如阿登纳，第一任总理。是的，比如康拉德·阿登纳。他们说，让我们用《德国人之歌》。
Let's have the, you know, it worked for the Weimar Republic. It was popular in the 1840s. Perfect. But a lot of people say, no, it's too tainted. It was the official anthem during the third right. You can't have it. So to start with, they have no anthem at all because they can't agree. And when they have public events, they will often play Beethoven's Ode to Joy,
让我们用它，你知道，它对魏玛共和国很有效。它在1840年代很受欢迎。完美。但很多人说，不，它被玷污得太厉害了。它是第三帝国时期的官方国歌。你不能用它。所以起初，他们根本没有国歌，因为他们无法达成一致。当他们举行公共活动时，他们经常播放贝多芬的《欢乐颂》，
which of course has words by the playwright Schiller. So there's that. At other official events, madly, they play a carnival song called the Trizonesia song. And this is written by a jokester from Cologne. So Alia, our producer, is from Cologne. This guy's from Cologne, too. And he was called Carl Berbauer. A German jokester.
当然，歌词是由剧作家席勒创作的。所以就是这样。在其他官方活动中，疯狂的是，他们播放了一首名为《特里佐内西亚之歌》的狂欢节歌曲。这是由科隆的一位小丑创作的。所以阿利亚，我们的制片人，来自科隆。这家伙也来自科隆。他叫卡尔·贝尔鲍尔。一个德国小丑。
A German funster. He wrote it for the Cologne Carnival at the end of 1948. And the great joke here is that with Germany having been divided into different parts, West Germany is made up of three of these three zones. And so they all live in this made-up Tri-Zonezier. Oh, yeah, very good. And the chorus, it's the most West German thing imaginable. So when I picture West Germany, I picture people in the beer hall in 1972
一位德国的滑稽艺人。他在1948年底为科隆狂欢节创作了这首歌。这里最大的笑话是，德国被分裂成了不同的部分，西德由这三个区组成。所以他们都生活在这个虚构的“三区尼亚”。哦，是的，非常好。而副歌部分，简直是你能想象到的最西德的东西。所以当我想到西德时，我脑海中浮现的是1972年啤酒馆里的人们，
laughing and slapping their thighs as they turn out, Audi's and BMWs. In my imagination, they're singing this, because this is the song. We are the natives of Trizonezia. Heidi Shimola Shimola Shimola bum We have maidens with fiery wild natures Heidi Shimola Shimola Shimula bum We may not be cannibals
他们一边大笑，一边拍着大腿，同时生产着奥迪和宝马。在我的想象中，他们正在唱这首歌，因为这就是那首歌。我们是三区尼亚的土著。海蒂·希莫拉·希莫拉·希莫拉·蹦，我们有天性狂野火辣的少女，海蒂·希莫拉·希莫拉·希莫拉·蹦，我们可能不是食人族，
But we kiss all the better for it We are the natives of Trizonesia Heidi Shimola Shimala Shimla bum Does it have a comedy tune Undoubtedly, surely an umpah band That's what it is I would imagine Yeah Now this song starts as a joke
但我们吻起来却更带劲。我们是三区尼亚的土著。海蒂·希莫拉·希莫拉·希莫拉·蹦。它有喜剧曲调吗？毫无疑问，肯定是一支铜管乐队。就是那种感觉。我想象是这样。是的。现在这首歌最初只是个玩笑，
And actually people start to They think it's serious and they start playing it seriously. I mean, Callum says quite correctly that it would win Eurovision. It totally would win Eurovision. It's a very 70s Eurovision though, I think. Yeah. Yeah.
实际上人们开始……他们以为这是认真的，于是开始认真地演奏它。我的意思是，卡勒姆说得很对，这首歌能赢得欧洲歌唱大赛。它绝对能赢。不过我觉得这非常有70年代欧洲歌唱大赛的风格。是的。是的。
Banga, banga, boom. Actually, so they hosted a cycle race in Cologne, Kuhl, in 1949. And this was played as the German. And a lot of German politicians just said, this is such, I mean, we've disgraced ourselves recently in multiple ways. Yes, with the whole fascism thing. with the Nazis and business, but this is almost as bad. This is terrible. This is even worse. And the Chancellor of West Germany, Conrad Adenauer, who was a former mayor of Cologne, so he basically had, you know, this was personal for him.
蹦，蹦，蹦。实际上，他们在1949年的科隆举办了一场自行车赛。这首歌被当作德国国歌播放了。许多德国政客只是说，这太……我的意思是，我们最近在多方面丢尽了脸。是的，整个法西斯主义的事情。纳粹和那些事，但这几乎一样糟糕。这太可怕了。这甚至更糟。而西德总理康拉德·阿登纳，他曾是科隆市长，所以他基本上……你知道，这对他是私事。
He gave a press conference in April 1950, and he said to the press, several Belgian military personnel were present in uniform and eventually the national anthems were played. The band struck up this lovely carnival song. Numerous Belgian soldiers stood up and saluted, believing it to be the national anthem. And Adana said, this isn't shaming for Germany. Like, come on, bring back the song on the Germans. This is nonsense. This shimula, shimula, shimula, shimula, bum, business. And actually, polls showed that Adanah spoke for the majority. So seven out of ten people in the early 50s said, come on, we want the old one back. The problem, though, was that the president of Germany was a guy called Tejodor Hoyse, and he was a liberal free Democrat. And he said, no, way. That's a Nazi song. You can't have that back. And he actually commissioned his own rival
他在1950年4月召开了一次新闻发布会，他对媒体说，当时有几名比利时军人身着制服在场，最终国歌被演奏了。乐队奏响了这首可爱的狂欢节歌曲。许多比利时士兵站起来敬礼，以为这是国歌。阿登纳说，这并不是德国的耻辱。拜托，让德国人把这首歌带回来吧。这简直是胡说八道。什么希莫拉、希莫拉、希莫拉、希莫拉、蹦之类的。实际上，民调显示阿登纳代表了大多数人的意见。所以50年代初，十个人里有七个说，拜托，我们要把旧国歌找回来。但问题是，当时的德国总统是一个叫特奥多尔·豪斯的家伙，他是一位自由民主党人。他说，没门。那是纳粹歌曲。你们不能把它找回来。他甚至委托创作了自己的竞争对手，
song called A Hymn to Germany by a Protestant hymn writer, which was very dull. Land of Faith, German land, land of fathers and heirs, land of faith, German land. It just goes on and on like that. And that never caught on. Adonauer campaigned and campaigned for the song of the Germans. He used to get people to sing it at rallies, which was very controversial. And finally, after a massive standoff. He wrote to this bloke Hoist, the president. He said, this has gone much too long. I'm sick of this now. I'm formally, officially asking you, approve this lead de Deutsche as our national anthem. And Hoyst, the president, cracked and he said, all right, fine, as long as we can sing only the third verse, not the first two. It's often thought the first two are banned. They're not banned, actually.
一首名为《德国赞歌》的歌，由一位新教赞美诗作者创作，非常沉闷。信仰之地，德国土地，先辈与继承者之地，信仰之地，德国土地。它就这样没完没了地唱下去。那首歌从未流行起来。阿登纳不断地为《德国人之歌》奔走呼吁。他过去常让人们在集会上唱这首歌，这非常有争议。最终，在一次巨大的僵局之后，他写信给那个叫豪斯的总统。他说，这已经拖得太久了。我对此感到厌倦了。我正式、官方地要求你，批准这首《德国人之歌》作为我们的国歌。而总统豪斯妥协了，他说，好吧，没问题，只要我们只唱第三段，不唱前两段。人们常以为前两段被禁了。其实它们并没有被禁。
It's a convention that you don't, you know, it starts as a convention that you don't sing them. So by this point they're worried about the sexism angle as well as the whole. Yeah, I think so. Kind of conquering people misinterpretation. Yeah, the sort of ha-ha, German wine and women and song. I think wine, women and song, if you're a woman, it's kind of, are you going to sing that with joy? I mean, surely not. At the time, when the news got out, they were adopting the old anthem, a lot of the foreign press,
这只是一种惯例，你知道，它始于一种不唱它们的惯例。所以到这个时候，他们不仅担心整个……是的，我想也是。那种征服者的误解。是的，那种“哈哈，德国的酒、女人和歌”。我想，如果你是个女人，你会高兴地唱“酒、女人和歌”吗？我的意思是，肯定不会。当时，当消息传出他们要采用旧国歌时，许多外国媒体，
you can imagine what people made of this in our own dear country. they were displeased. They said, oh, the Germans, they haven't changed. They're back at it again. Yeah. First, you know, one minute they're bringing back the old anthem, the next they're marching into Poland. Yeah.
你可以想象人们在我们亲爱的国家对此作何感想。他们很不高兴。他们说，哦，德国人，他们根本没变。他们又重操旧业了。是的。第一，你知道，前一分钟他们还在恢复旧国歌，下一分钟他们就要进军波兰了。是的。
And the first big flashpoint, actually, since this is a series tied to the World Cup, it comes at the World Cup. So some people may remember this from when we did a series about the history of the World Cup tournament back in 2022. The World Cup was held in Switzerland in 1954,
而第一个大的爆发点，实际上，因为这是一个与世界杯挂钩的系列节目，它出现在世界杯上。所以有些人可能还记得我们在2022年做关于世界杯历史的系列节目时提到过这一点。世界杯于1954年在瑞士举行，
and the big favorites were Hungary who hadn't lost for 32 games. They played West German in the final. This was the first exhibition of the Germans' irritating habit of making implausible comebacks from the brink of defeat. The Hungarians went 2-0 up after 8 minutes and the Germans came back to win 3-2. And this was a massive moment in the cultural history of West Germany.
当时最大的夺冠热门是匈牙利队，他们已经32场比赛未尝败绩。他们在决赛中对阵西德。这是德国人那种从失败边缘实现不可思议逆转的恼人习惯的首次展示。匈牙利人在8分钟内就以2-0领先，而德国人最终以3-2反超获胜。这是西德文化史上一个巨大的时刻。
The historian Joachim Fest caused it the true birth of the country, no less. And when the German captain Fritz Valter went up to collect the World Cup trophy, A Swiss band starts playing the German national anthem. And the German fans in the crowd, who had been drinking, of course, start to sing the first verse. Deutschland Uber Alice. Oh, yeah, the menacing one. And it is said that, now this is very much a sort of ancient history, it is said that.
历史学家约阿希姆·费斯特称其为这个国家的真正诞生，一点也不为过。当德国队长弗里茨·瓦尔特上去领取世界杯奖杯时，一支瑞士乐队开始演奏德国国歌。而人群中的德国球迷，当然已经喝了不少酒，开始唱第一段。《德国高于一切》。哦，是的，那首带有威胁意味的歌。据说，现在这已经是非常古老的历史了，据说，
Swiss radio was so shocked they cut the broadcast. I don't know whether that's actually true because the only source for that is, football journalism written in the 1990s. Or from the Swiss, perhaps, trying to pretend that they were braver in standing up to the Germans than they actually were. The Swiss would never do that. Have the Swiss any history of doing that?
瑞士电台当时太震惊了，以至于切断了广播。我不知道这是否属实，因为唯一的来源是20世纪90年代写的足球新闻。或者也许是瑞士人试图假装他们比实际表现得更勇敢，敢于对抗德国人。瑞士人绝不会那样做。瑞士人有那样的历史吗？
Surely not? Anyway, the fact that they've been singing the wrong words, the old words, is reported in the world's press. And what is then worse, the president of the German Football Association, Pico Bowens, who was a former member of the Nazi party, gave a celebratory speech in a Munich beer hall. I mean, Jesus, of all the places
肯定没有吧？不管怎样，他们唱错了歌词、唱了旧歌词的事实被世界媒体报道了。更糟糕的是，德国足协主席皮科·鲍文斯，他曾是纳粹党成员，在慕尼黑的一个啤酒馆发表了庆祝演讲。我的天，在所有地方里，
to best, to give a celebratory speech. And he said, brilliant, we've won the World Cup. Our players were inspired by Wotan and Thor and all this. And the West German president we've already met, Teodor Hoyce, he was appalled by this. And actually, at the official public celebrations at the Olympic Stadium, which were attended by 80,000 people in Berlin, West Berlin, he publicly reprimanded the head of the German F.A., and then he said he read out the third verse of the anthem, Einichit and Rechten, Freit, and he said, this is our anthem, I want the whole stadium to sing it. And do they sing it? Yeah, which they did.
竟然选在那里发表庆祝演讲。他说，太棒了，我们赢得了世界杯。我们的球员受到了沃坦和托尔的启发，诸如此类。而我们已经见过的西德总统特奥多尔·豪斯对此感到震惊。实际上，在柏林奥林匹克体育场举行的有8万人参加的官方公开庆祝活动上，他公开训斥了德国足协主席，然后他说，他朗读了国歌的第三段，“统一、正义与自由”，他说，这就是我们的国歌，我要整个体育场的人都唱它。他们唱了吗？是的，他们唱了。
Because that's always risky asking a load of football fans to sing a particular song. I mean, you're kind of asking for trouble. And never, ever. Anyone who's been to a football match knows that asking the crowd to do anything never, ever works. Now, I'll tell you who's watching this with glee. That is West Germany's neighbors in East Germany. Of course they would be, wouldn't they? Because the East Germans have always said,
因为让一大群足球迷唱一首特定的歌总是很冒险。我的意思是，你简直是在自找麻烦。而且永远，永远不会。任何去过足球比赛的人都知道，要求观众做任何事都永远不会奏效。现在，我告诉你谁在幸灾乐祸地看着这一切。那就是西德的邻居东德。当然会是他们，不是吗？因为东德人一直说，
the Federal Republic, West Germany, is basically the Third Reich and a cuddlier guy is. And they say, well, this is the proof. So one paper in East Berlin said, oh, well, our neighbors have let the cat out of the bag. They're just the Nazis. When fascists start singing Deutschland Uber Alas and a horsed vessel song that has nothing to do with sports. but to do with death.
联邦共和国，即西德，基本上就是第三帝国的翻版，只是看起来更可爱一点。他们说，好吧，这就是证据。所以东柏林的一份报纸说，哦，好吧，我们的邻居露出了马脚。他们就是纳粹。当法西斯分子开始唱《德国高于一切》和《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》时，这与体育无关，而是与死亡有关。
But they're not singing the horse vessel song. No, I think that's untrue. That's a massive exaggeration. That's a massive exaggeration. It's very unfair. They didn't sing the horse vessel song at all. And I mean, unless the head of the German Fethe was doing it in his beer hall when he wasn't toasting Wooten out of the skull, no doubt.
但他们并没有唱《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》。不，我认为那是不真实的。那是巨大的夸张。那是巨大的夸张。这非常不公平。他们根本没有唱《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》。我的意思是，除非德国足协主席在啤酒馆里，在用头骨杯向沃坦敬酒时唱了，毫无疑问。
That would definitely have been reported if he had. I mean, it would have been so punchy for them to have sung the horse festival song after winning the World Cup in the fifties. And they didn't do it. I mean, I want to stress, they didn't do it. Now, of course, the East Germans have a different song at this point. they have adopted a new anthem with none of the shilly-shallying in democratic, in weak democratic, West Germany.
如果他唱了，那肯定会被报道出来。我的意思是，如果他们在50年代赢得世界杯后唱了《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》，那对他们来说太有冲击力了。但他们没唱。我的意思是，我想强调，他们没唱。现在，当然，东德人在这个时候有一首不同的歌。他们采用了一首新国歌，在软弱的民主西德，没有那种犹豫不决。
This is the great positive, Tom, I living in a totalitarian dictatorship. You can decide instantly. So within three days of the foundation of East Germany in October 1949, the president, who was a Stalinist called Wilhelm Peak, he set the ball rolling. He commissioned a text from somebody he'd known in exile in Moscow, who was an avant-garde, There's a lot of poets in this. Johannes Becker. No relation to Boris. No relation to Boris.
这是伟大的积极之处，汤姆，生活在极权独裁统治下。你可以立即做出决定。所以，在1949年10月东德成立后的三天内，总统，一个叫威廉·皮克的斯大林主义者，他启动了这件事。他委托一位他在莫斯科流亡时认识的人创作了歌词，那个人是一位先锋派……这里面有很多诗人。约翰内斯·贝歇尔。和鲍里斯没关系。和鲍里斯没关系。
And the title of the new anthem was Alfechstanden oustruinen. And the opening lines in English, From the ruins newly risen to the future turned, we stand. Let us serve your welfare truly. Germany, our fatherland. I mean, that's not kind of overtly communist, is it? No, well, we'll come to this. The lyrics are not overtly communist.
新国歌的标题是《从废墟中崛起》。英文开头的几句是：从废墟中新近崛起，面向未来，我们站立。让我们真诚地为您服务。德国，我们的祖国。我的意思是，那听起来不是那种公开的共产主义，对吧？不，好吧，我们稍后会谈到这一点。歌词并不是公开的共产主义。
And actually, what's really interesting, just before we get to the lyrics, the tune is compatible with Haydn's tune. Oh. You could sing it to the old tune. They don't, they? They don't. They commissioned competing tunes by two guys who sang them. They put on performances at the Cultural Workers Club in East Berlin, and the Politburo voted. So kind of communist Eurovision.
实际上，非常有趣的是，在我们谈到歌词之前，它的曲调与海顿的曲调是兼容的。哦。你可以用旧曲调唱它。他们没那样做，对吧？他们没有。他们委托两个人创作了竞争性的曲调，并让他们演唱。他们在东柏林的文化工作者俱乐部进行了表演，政治局进行了投票。所以这算是一种共产主义的欧洲歌唱大赛。
Communist Eurovision. And they voted for a tour. tuned by a guy called Hans Eisler. Isler was a communist of very long standing. He'd been a member since he was 14. He'd been exiled. This is a great, great story, actually. The guy he wrote the East German anthem had been exiled to the United States
共产主义的欧洲歌唱大赛。他们投票选出了一首由汉斯·艾斯勒创作的曲子。艾斯勒是一位资深的共产主义者。他从14岁起就是成员。他曾被流放。这其实是一个非常非常棒的故事。那个为东德创作国歌的人曾被流放到美国，
during the Third Reich. He was accused when he was in America of being a Soviet agent. Was he? And sort of McCarthyism. I think he probably a bit was, because he was a communist. Probably was a bit. Yeah, he was the Stalinist. They called him, the American press called him the Karl Marx of music.
在第三帝国时期。他在美国时被指控为苏联特工。他是吗？还有麦卡锡主义之类的。我想他可能确实有一点，因为他是个共产主义者。可能确实有一点。是的，他是个斯大林主义者。他们称他为，美国媒体称他为“音乐界的卡尔·马克思”。
I like that. Surely that's belly brag, isn't it? He was put on a Hollywood blacklist and he was deported. Well, he's a communist. Of course he was put on a Hollywood blacklist. Yeah, but deported is harsh. I mean, he literally was a communist. He literally was a communist.
我喜欢这个。这肯定是自吹自擂，对吧？他被列入了“好莱坞黑名单”并被驱逐出境。好吧，他是个共产主义者。他当然会被列入好莱坞黑名单。是的，但驱逐出境太严厉了。我的意思是，他确实是个共产主义者。他确实是个共产主义者。
You're right. He was deported in 1948. Right. That's the debit side. On the credit side, I'm just going to absolutely pin my colors to the mast, my East German colors. I think his anthem, the East German anthem, is an absolute all-time banger. And for me, and I know you'll say I hate Britain, but I'm just going to, I think there's
你说得对。他于1948年被驱逐出境。对。那是负面的一面。在正面的一面，我打算坚定地表明我的立场，我的东德立场。我认为他的国歌，东德国歌，绝对是一首史上最棒的歌。对我来说，我知道你会说我讨厌英国，但我还是要说，我认为有，
only one better anthem, and that's the anthem of the Soviet Union. I think they are brilliant anthems. Madness. You do hate Britain. So a couple of interesting things about the anthem. First of all, Isler said, I've written it as a humanistic anthem, nothing jazzy, nothing military. And nothing about mountains and lakes or anything like that.
只有一首更好的国歌，那就是苏联国歌。我认为它们是出色的国歌。疯了。你确实讨厌英国。所以关于这首国歌有几件有趣的事。首先，艾斯勒说，我把它写成了一首人文主义的国歌，没有爵士乐，没有军事色彩。也没有关于山川湖泊之类的东西。
Not really, no. There were allegations that he ripped it off from an Austrian pop song from the 1930s. And actually, the Austrian bloke took the case to the United Nations Copyright Commission, but he didn't win. And can't just ask, what is the Austrian anthem by this point? Is it still the Hayden one, or have they moved on from that? No. So they had the Hayden tune right up to the Anselas, but then they dropped it when Austria was reborn in the 1940s. And they adopted a very boring anthem called Land Der Berger, Land Amsterdam.
确实没有。有指控称他抄袭了30年代的一首奥地利流行歌曲。实际上，那个奥地利人把案子告到了联合国版权委员会，但他没赢。我能问一下，当时的奥地利国歌是什么吗？还是海顿的那首，还是他们已经换了？没有。所以他们一直用海顿的曲调直到德奥合并，但当奥地利在40年代重生时，他们放弃了它。他们采用了一首非常无聊的国歌，叫《山峦之地，河流之地》。
Land of the peaks, land by the stream. So one of the generic geographical anthems. What a falling off was there. Yeah, exactly. Dispointing from the Austrians. But the other interesting thing about the East German anthem is it was designed not as the anthem of East Germany, but it's the anthem of all Germany.
山峰之地，河流之畔。所以是那种通用的地理国歌之一。那真是退步了。是的，确实。奥地利人让人失望。但东德国歌的另一个有趣之处在于，它被设计出来的目的不是作为东德的国歌，而是作为全德国的国歌。
Oh, right. Because at this point, the East Germans claim basically all Germany. And so the first verse explicitly mentions Deutschland Eich Vaterland You know, I would love to hear this at the end of the episode We will play it at the end of the episode Because it is such a banger Deutscheland, a United Fatherland
哦，对。因为在这一点上，东德人基本上声称代表整个德国。所以第一段明确提到了“德国，统一的祖国”。你知道，我真想在节目结束时听到这个。我们会在节目结束时播放它，因为它太棒了。德国，统一的祖国。
This is for Dominic Stambrook His favourite song My Desert Island disc selection Which one is it to be Always the showmanee There's nothing communist about the lyrics Yet you were right about that So there's nothing about workers
这是给多米尼克·斯坦布鲁克的。他最喜欢的歌。我的“荒岛唱片”选择。到底是哪一首？永远是表演者。歌词里没有任何共产主义的东西。你刚才说得对。所以里面没有关于工人的，
There's nothing about peasants That the word socialism never appears There's nothing about class struggle it's all kind of the shining sun, youth, peace, things that I stand for, Tom. Yeah. No wonder you love it. Yeah, German youngsters laughing in the sunshine. That's what I'm all about.
没有关于农民的。社会主义这个词从未出现。没有关于阶级斗争的内容。全是关于灿烂的阳光、青春、和平，这些我所支持的东西，汤姆。是的。难怪你喜欢它。是的，德国年轻人在阳光下欢笑。这就是我所追求的。
And actually, it was not controversial at the time. So this is a very unusual example of a national anthem that didn't provoke any controversy. The DDR, the East German authorities, made a great effort to push it. They played it in public. They put it banners with the lyrics. They made children sing it in school. But there's a historian, a German historian called Haika Amos. And she's looked into this and she says all the evidence from party reports and stuff
实际上，它在当时并没有引起争议。所以这是一个非常罕见的国歌例子，没有引发任何争议。民主德国，即东德当局，付出了巨大努力来推广它。他们在公共场合播放它。他们挂出印有歌词的横幅。他们让孩子们在学校里唱它。但有一位德国历史学家叫海克·阿莫斯。她研究过这个问题，她说所有来自党内报告之类的证据，
is that, you know, when people are reporting about it, they said people actually love this anthem. They can't get enough of it. It becomes a part of an integral part of life in East Germany. And a much-loved part of it. Yeah. Like a travant. Like a state-sponsored Weeks holiday in some sand dunes. On the Baltic.
都表明，你知道，当人们报告这件事时，他们说人们实际上很喜欢这首国歌。他们百听不厌。它成为了东德生活中不可或缺的一部分。而且是深受喜爱的一部分。是的。就像特拉班特汽车一样。就像在波罗的海沙丘上享受国家资助的几周假期一样。
While the starsy watch you from behind a load of reeds. That's less loved, isn't it? it. Yeah. So in East Germany, you would do a ceremony when you were 14, and this is when you became an adult and got your identity papers and pledged yourself towards the defence of socialism. It was called the Jungendvaier Youth Consecration Ceremony, and you would have to sing all three verses of the East German anthem. So I would have enjoyed that. I would have very much enjoyed it. Anyway, there was a twist in the late 60s after the building of the Berlin Wall. It is obvious that East Germany's ambitions to become all Germany are going to be frustrated, basically because
当斯塔西在芦苇丛后监视你时。这不太讨人喜欢，对吧？是的。在东德，你会在14岁时举行一个仪式，这是你成年、获得身份证件并宣誓保卫社会主义的时刻。它被称为“青年礼”，你必须唱完东德国歌的所有三段歌词。所以我应该会喜欢那个仪式。我会非常喜欢的。总之，在60年代末柏林墙建立后，情况发生了变化。很明显，东德成为全德国的野心将会受挫，主要是因为
East Germany is terrible and everyone's trying to escape. And then in the early 70s, both Germans are admitted to the United Nations as separate states. And so about this point, the East Germans start to discourage people from singing this great anthem because they don't want people to think about Deutschland, Einich Faderland, a united fatherland. Actually, what they're trying to do now in the 70s is to tell people, you know, the idea of a United Germany was always mad. East Germany has always been different. West Germany is full of Catholics. We've always been Protestant and Lutheran.
东德太糟糕了，每个人都想逃离。到了70年代初，东西德作为两个独立的国家被联合国接纳。就在这一点上，东德人开始劝阻人们唱这首伟大的国歌，因为他们不想让人们想到“统一的祖国”。实际上，他们在70年代试图做的是告诉人们，统一德国的想法一直都是疯狂的。东德一直与众不同。西德到处都是天主教徒，而我们一直是新教徒和路德宗信徒。
We have our own separate traditions. We have our own cultural identity. Let's stop singing this song about United Fatherland. So madly, they now have a situation where you do the anthem at school, you stand for it, it plays, but you are discouraged from singing. Oh, so they don't just replace it and come up with new lyrics. or something. No, which they should have done. I mean, why not just change the words? I suppose because changing the words would mean some sort of admission that they'd been wrong, which they don't want to do. Yeah. So anyway, this is the position all the way through to the fall of the Berlin Wall.
我们有自己独立的传统。我们有自己的文化认同。让我们停止唱这首关于统一祖国的歌吧。所以疯狂的是，他们现在的情况是，你在学校里唱国歌，你起立致敬，音乐响起，但你被劝阻不要唱。哦，所以他们没有直接替换它并想出新的歌词之类的。没有，他们本应该这么做的。我的意思是，为什么不直接改词呢？我想因为改词意味着承认他们错了，而他们不想这样做。是的。总之，这就是直到柏林墙倒塌前的情况。
There are two anthems. There's the song of the Germans in the West. There's Alfa Shandanao's Ruinen in the East. Then the Berlin Wall falls. The two Germans are going to be reunited. And the question is, which anthem are they going to pick? Well, it's obvious, isn't it? I mean, I'll go with the West German one because the West German one's basically swallowing it. No, it's not obvious. So, first of all, the song of the Germans has been massively controversial all the way through in West Germany. Poles in the 70s and the 80s found that sort of lefty West Germans didn't like it. They said it's reactionary.
有两首国歌。西德有《德国人之歌》，东德有《从废墟中崛起》。然后柏林墙倒塌了。两个德国即将统一。问题是，他们会选择哪首国歌？嗯，这很明显，不是吗？我的意思是，我会选西德的那首，因为西德的那首基本上是吞并了东德。不，这并不明显。首先，《德国人之歌》在西德一直极具争议。70年代和80年代的波兰人发现，那种左翼西德人不喜欢它。他们说这是反动的。
It's a relic of Nazism. You know, if you're sort of Bardem Einhoff adjacent, you're not a fan of this anthem. You have those kind of stickers with the Smiley Sun that's against nuclear power. Completely. You're going on demonstrations against Pershing missiles, and you hate Ronald Reagan. 99 red balloons. Precisely. Meanwhile, on the right of West German politics, people, Christian Democrat politicians keep trying to sneak the old words back in, Deutschland, Uberas. They keep trying to get that first verse in. They love that first verse. Like helmet Cole, trying to slip down another pig's knuckle. Exactly. So, if,
这是纳粹主义的遗迹。你知道，如果你是那种巴德尔-迈因霍夫（恐怖组织）倾向的人，你就不会是这首国歌的粉丝。你会贴那种反对核能的笑脸太阳贴纸。完全正确。你会去参加反对潘兴导弹的示威活动，而且你讨厌罗纳德·里根。《99个红气球》。正是如此。与此同时，在西德政治右翼，基督教民主党政客们一直试图偷偷把旧歌词塞回去，“德国高于一切”。他们一直试图把第一段加进去。他们喜欢那第一段。就像赫尔穆特·科尔，试图再塞进一个猪蹄。正是如此。所以，如果，
every now and again. And it's always, but this always happens in Baden-Vurttemberg. Every now and again, Barden-Vurttemberg, there'll be a controversy because it'll turn out
时不时地。而且总是这样，但这总是在巴登-符腾堡州发生。时不时地，巴登-符腾堡州就会出现争议，因为结果会发现
that some local politician has been trying to get schools to sing the first of the anthem. And meanwhile, you know, anti-nuclear green campaigners say he should be tired and feathered
当地的一些政客一直试图让学校唱国歌的第一段。与此同时，你知道，反核的绿党活动人士说他应该被涂上焦油和羽毛
in, you know, as punishment. So there's that. Meanwhile, there's the issue that 17 million East Germans have been brought up to believe that the song of the Germans
作为惩罚。所以就是这样。与此同时，还有一个问题，1700万东德人从小就被灌输认为《德国人之歌》
is an evil capitalist relic of, you know, Nazism and militarism and stuff. So the last Prime Minister of East Germany, who is a guy who Lota de Mésier, suggested a compromise. He said, well, do you know what? We can use our lyrics with your tune. Why don't we have Haydn's tune and the East German lyrics? Yeah. I mean, that's quite a neat idea. It is a neat idea.
是纳粹主义和军国主义的邪恶资本主义遗迹。所以东德的最后一位总理，一个叫洛塔尔·德梅齐埃的人，提出了一个折中方案。他说，好吧，你知道吗？我们可以用我们的歌词配你们的曲子。为什么我们不用海顿的曲子配东德的歌词呢？是的。我的意思是，那是个很巧妙的主意。确实是个巧妙的主意。
And it's a kind of prefiguring of what we're going to be talking about in our last episode about South Africa. Yeah. Where there are similar agonized debates and actually a very effective compromise has arrived at. Very good compromise, exactly. And the West Germans, Helmut Cole rouse, you know, lifts himself from the gravy to say. No way. He says, no way. These are the lyrics of a, you know, a cruel dictatorship.
这预示了我们将在最后一集讨论的关于南非的话题。是的。那里也有类似的痛苦辩论，实际上达成了一个非常有效的妥协。非常好的妥协，确实。而西德的赫尔穆特·科尔，你知道，从肉汁中抬起头来说，没门。他说，没门。这些是一个残酷独裁政权的歌词。
We're never going to have the lyrics that were sung by the Starzy and the people who built the Berlin Wall. You can forget your lyrics. So at this point, Germanist intellectuals say, well, there is another song. And this is the song that we alluded to right at the beginning. But you said your friend likes, but we haven't mentioned. And this is a song written by Bertolt Brecht by one of Germany's best known playwrights, one of Germany's best known 20th century intellectuals. Brecht in the 1950s wrote this.
我们绝不会使用由斯塔西和那些建造柏林墙的人唱的歌词。你可以忘了你的歌词。所以此时，德国知识分子说，嗯，还有另一首歌。这就是我们在开头提到的那首歌。但你说你朋友喜欢，我们还没提到。这是一首由德国最著名的剧作家之一、德国最著名的20世纪知识分子之一贝尔托·布莱希特写的歌。布莱希特在50年代写了这首歌。
And it's called the Kinderdihimna, the Children's Anthembourg, the children's anthem. And again, it's a sort of compromise because he wrote it in response to Adanauer's decision to bring back the old anthem in West Germany. And he had it set to music by the bloke who wrote the music, Eisler, the Karl Marx of music for East Germany. So if you look it up online, Brecht's Children's Anthem, you can see, A, why people on the left love it and why everybody else thinks it's mad. Because basically, it's massively self-flagellating. So the second verse explicitly says,
它被称为《儿童赞美诗》，即儿童国歌。同样，这是一种妥协，因为他是为了回应阿登纳决定在西德恢复旧国歌而写的。他请写音乐的人艾斯勒为它谱曲，艾斯勒是东德音乐界的卡尔·马克思。所以如果你在网上查一下，布莱希特的《儿童赞美诗》，你可以看到，A，为什么左翼人士喜欢它，以及为什么其他人认为它很疯狂。因为基本上，它在极度自我鞭笞。
our great hope is that other countries will no longer recoil from us in horror at our crimes. I mean, we could have that. A lot of countries could have that. Well, I think no country. It's very unusual to have a national anthem in which you flagellate yourselves. And the third verse says explicitly, and not over, not under, and then vilken, will we be.
我们伟大的希望是，其他国家不再因我们的罪行而对我们感到恐惧。我的意思是，我们可以有那个。很多国家都可以有那个。嗯，我想没有国家。拥有一首自我鞭笞的国歌是非常罕见的。第三段明确写道，不高于，不低于，然后是各国人民。
And not over and not under other nations will we be. But you know my favourite lines from it? Go on. It may seem dearest to us, just as other people's countries seem dearest to them. I mean, that's a banging lyric. Yeah, yeah. I mean, imagine that at the World Cup.
我们不会高于也不低于其他国家。但你知道我最喜欢其中的哪几句吗？说吧。它可能对我们最亲，就像其他国家的土地对他们最亲一样。我的意思是，那是一句很棒的歌词。是的，是的。我的意思是，想象一下在世界杯上唱这个。
Someone has a massively bombastic anthem. And then the Germans smugly sing, well, you know. We know better than anybody else. Yeah, it may seem dearest to us, but doesn't everyone think that? You're playing Paragrai or somebody. You have an incredibly strutting anthem about the glories of a Sunsian. And then the Germans sing, you know, we're very sorry, we're behaved poorly. Please don't record from us in horror anymore.
有人唱着极其浮夸的国歌。然后德国人自嘲地唱着，嗯，你知道。我们比任何人都更清楚。是的，它可能对我们最亲，但难道每个人不都这么想吗？你正在和巴拉圭或其他什么人比赛。你有一首极其傲慢的关于某人荣耀的国歌。然后德国人唱着，你知道，我们很抱歉，我们表现得很糟糕。请不要再因我们的罪行而对我们感到恐惧了。
The end result of all this is they end up sticking with the Weimar anthem. That's the song with the Germans, third verse. Einichite and Recht and Freitait, so unity and right and freedom. And this becomes basically the motto of the reunited Germany. Those words, Einichite and Rehecht and Freight, they are printed on the belt buckles today of German soldiers. They are printed, they are engraved on the edge of every two euro coin that is minted in Germany. But as with the first two anthems that we talked about, the arguments just do not go away. So in the late 1990s, the Green Party in Germany said,
这一切的最终结果是，他们最终坚持使用魏玛共和国的国歌。也就是《德国人之歌》的第三段。统一、正义和自由，这基本上成为了统一后德国的座右铭。这些词，统一、正义和自由，今天被印在德国士兵的皮带扣上。它们被刻在德国铸造的每一枚两欧元硬币的边缘上。但正如我们谈到的前两首国歌一样，争论并没有消失。所以在90年代末，德国绿党说，
we've made a massive mistake. We should have Brecht's anthem after all. We should have the flagellating anthem. We cannot go on having a national anthem whose first verse is sung by the radical right and whose third verse is sung by conservatives. An anthem sung by conservatives, the horror. People still make this case today.
我们犯了一个巨大的错误。我们毕竟应该用布莱希特的国歌。我们应该用那首自我鞭笞的国歌。我们不能继续使用一首第一段被激进右翼唱、第三段被保守派唱的国歌。一首被保守派唱的国歌，太可怕了。人们今天仍然提出这个观点。
But since this is a World Cup associated podcast, we'll just end with the 2006 World Cup, because that, I think, is the key moment for Germany and its embrace of its anthem. This was the first time that a united Germany had hosted the World Cup, and there was a big debate before the tournament about the anthem. And lots of commentators said, the problem we have is that the eyes of the world will be honest, lots of people will not be singing the anthem. Des Spiegel, very prestigious German paper, said,
但既然这是一个与世界杯相关的播客，我们就以2006年世界杯结束吧，因为我认为那是德国拥抱其国歌的关键时刻。这是统一后的德国第一次举办世界杯，在比赛前关于国歌有一场大辩论。许多评论员说，我们面临的问题是全世界的目光都盯着我们，很多人不会唱国歌。《明镜周刊》，一份非常有声望的德国报纸，说，
A historic opportunity was missed back in the 50s because these verses no longer work today. anyone who sings unity and justice and freedom knows that there are also two other undesirable verses and in today's Germany they sound about as modern as a teacher with a cane in a high school. Anyway, the Spiegel was wrong because actually loads of Germans did sing the anthem and nobody complained at all. And the German broadcaster Deutsche Vela said after the tournament, the site of the German team, their arms around one another as dash Deutschland lead, another way of putting the song in the Germans as the Germany song played
50年代错失了一个历史性的机会，因为这些歌词在今天已经不再适用了。任何唱着统一、正义和自由的人都知道，还有另外两段不受欢迎的歌词，在今天的德国，它们听起来就像高中里拿着藤条的老师一样过时。总之，《明镜周刊》错了，因为实际上很多德国人都唱了国歌，而且没有人抱怨。德国广播公司德国之声在比赛后说，德国队队员们互相搂着肩膀，唱着《德国人之歌》的场景
was an emotional moment for many of us. It seems that football has done what politics could never do, give a voice to a generation to whom patriotism is not a dirty word and maybe it's okay to be a German and proud of it after all. Yeah, I mean the biggest controversy of that World Cup was all the wags going shopping.
对我们许多人来说是一个感人的时刻。看来足球做到了政治永远无法做到的事情，给那一代人发出了声音，对他们来说爱国主义不是一个肮脏的词，也许做一个德国人并为此感到自豪毕竟是可以的。是的，我的意思是那届世界杯最大的争议是所有的球员太太团去购物。
In Barden, Barden, and distracting our brave boys from more important things like scoring penalties. More bad behaviour in Baden-Verdtemberg. everything that's terrible happens there. Exactly. It all goes back to that, doesn't it?
在巴登-巴登，分散了我们勇敢的小伙子们对更重要事情的注意力，比如罚点球。巴登-符腾堡州又出现了更多糟糕的行为。所有糟糕的事情都发生在那里。正是如此。这一切都追溯到那里，不是吗？
Yeah, agreed. The wags let themselves down in that World Cup. I don't think they did. I mean, I enjoyed it. Posh spice. But England should have won that World Cup, Tom. We had a good team. We had a really good team.
是的，同意。球员太太团在那届世界杯上表现得很差。我不认为她们表现得很差。我的意思是，我很享受。辣妹维多利亚。但英格兰本应赢得那届世界杯，汤姆。我们有一支优秀的球队。我们有一支非常优秀的球队。
And we just played abysmally. The Golden Generation. But as for the anthems, my personal view is, I think it's a good anthem, the German anthem. Yeah, I like it. I think if I was German,
但我们踢得太糟糕了。黄金一代。但至于国歌，我个人的观点是，我认为这是一首好国歌，德国国歌。是的，我喜欢它。我想如果我是德国人，
I would sing it with great enthusiasm. I mean, let's bear in mind. Yeah. It's written by a guy who loved Nelson. What's not to like? I think that's either problem. Well, just to remind people, next time, the Netherlands, and then next week, Brazil and South Africa.
我会充满热情地唱它。我的意思是，让我们记住。是的。它是由一个热爱纳尔逊的人写的。有什么不喜欢的呢？我想那要么是问题所在。好吧，提醒大家，下次是荷兰，然后下周是巴西和南非。
But Tom, it would be remiss of us not to say at the very end that although the German anthem is good. It's not as good as East German. It's not as good as what they could have had. So, ladies and gentlemen, here it is Dominic Sam Brooks' Desert Island Disc. Take it away, Callum. Hello everybody. Now, as those of you who are good children will know, here in Britain, on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. But not just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on the 21st of June in the United States, in Canada and in the Republic of Ireland.
但汤姆，如果我们不在最后说一句，虽然德国国歌很好，但它不如东德的好，那我们就失职了。它不如他们本可以拥有的好。所以，女士们先生们，这就是多米尼克·桑布鲁克的“荒岛唱片”。开始吧，卡勒姆。大家好。现在，正如你们这些好孩子所知道的，在英国，6月21日是父亲节。但不仅仅是在英国。6月21日在美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国也是父亲节。
So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to the rest is history. And that is why we are offering an amazing. 25% Father's Day discount on the subscription price to the rest is history club because we are all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to full series. You get early access, that you get that with a membership. You get bonus episodes. You get ad free listening. You get access to tickets for live shows.
所以这四个国家被热爱收听《历史的其余部分》的父亲们团结在一起。这就是为什么我们提供了一个惊人的25%父亲节折扣，订阅《历史的其余部分》俱乐部，因为我们充满爱心。所以在这个父亲节，为你生命中的彼得大帝提供全系列的抢先体验。你获得抢先体验，那是会员资格的一部分。你获得额外剧集。你获得无广告收听。你获得现场演出门票的购买权。
Basically, you get an entire host of supplementary benefits. And that, I think, is what a lot of patriarchs want, isn't it? It absolutely is because I think nothing says, Happy Father's Day, quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours, ad-free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest ishistory.com and click on the word gifts. And that gift, membership of our much-loved Restis History Club, will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself.
基本上，你获得了一整套补充福利。而且我认为，这就是许多家长想要的，不是吗？绝对是，因为我认为没有什么比有机会连续六个小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能表达“父亲节快乐”了。是的，那是大多数父亲想要的。所以前往therestis-history.com并点击“礼物”一词。那份礼物，我们备受喜爱的《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的会员资格，将在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱中。
So if you want to give the best Father's Day gift that's ever been in history, ever, and we say this as the presenters of the Restis History, you know what to do. Are you one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets? Yes? Good, this is for you. Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different, locked in, loyal, invested. They're called fans. Fans don't just listen to music.
所以如果你想送出历史上最好的父亲节礼物，而且我们作为《历史的其余部分》的主持人这么说，你知道该怎么做。你是那些点击幻灯片、滚动电子表格的媒体策略人员之一吗？是的？很好，这是给你的。因为在Spotify上，有一群不同的、专注的、忠诚的、投入的听众。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不仅仅是听音乐。
They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them. So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to. And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo. So, are you ready to talk to fans? Spotify advertising. You're among fans. Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
他们感到被音乐所理解，就像音乐属于他们一样。所以当你的品牌出现在Spotify上时，你就是在和这些人对话。而且你就在像我这样的艺术家旁边，莉佐。那么，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？Spotify广告。你在粉丝之中。嘿大家，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过“如果……会怎样”？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？
That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what-if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果会怎样”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。